WE HAVE OUR OWN CONDITION AT.
OKAY WELCOME THANKS FOR JOINING
US TODAY AND SPECIAL THANKS TO
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE PALACE WHO
ARE ABLE TO MAKE IT TO THE
CAPITAL IN PERSON. AS A
REMINDER PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF
THE MASS REQUIREMENT AND
MAINTAIN PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
AND ONCE AGAIN THIS THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. AS A REMINDER PLEASE BE
MY FOR THE MASS REQUIREMENT AND
MAINTAIN PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
STAKEHOLDERS NOT APPEARING ON
THE PANEL TODAY AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC CAN ALSO PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S HEARING. BY CALLING.
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
USE INPUT AND USING PUBLIC ASK
ACCESS CODE. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. OR BY
SUBMITTING TESTIMONY IN WRITING
TO MY OFFICE. AS WE PROCEED
WITH THE GENERAL PUBLIC COMMENT
I WANT TO BE SURE THAT EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS ASSEMBLY HAS RULES
IN PLACE. TO ENSURE WE MAINTAIN
ORDER AND RUN AN EFFICIENT
HEARING. WE SEEK TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF ALL WHO PARTICIPATE
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. SO
THAT WE CAN EFFECTIVELY HAVE
DELIBERATIONS AND DECISIONS ON
THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING THE
INLAND EMPIRE. IN ORDER
FACILITATE THESE GOALS WILL NOT
PERMIT CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
THE SERBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THESE
PROCEEDINGS. THANK IN ADVANCE
FOR HEARING TO THESE PARTICLES.
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR ATTENDING THE FIRST
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. I REQUEST THE
SPEAKER GREAT THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE FRIDAY FOCUSED ON THE
INLAND EMPIRE NOW I'M SO
PLEASED BY THE INTERESTS OF THE
MANY COLLEAGUES. I KNOW I'M NOT
ALONE IN FEELING FORTUNATE TO
REPRESENT PART OF THE THIRD
LARGEST METROPOLITAN AREA IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE THIRTEEN
LARGEST IN THE NATION. RECENTLY
THIS THE STATE HAS BEGUN
RECOGNIZING THE VITAL ROLE THIS
REGION PLAYS AND HOW CENTER
THIS TOWARD THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA. THE BROOKINGS
INSTITUTION AS ESTIMATED 50% OF
THE WORKERS IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE HAVE JOBS THAT PROVIDE
INSUFFICIENT PAY OR BENEFITS.
AND NO FOR VIABLE CAREER
PATHWAY TO MORE LUCRATIVE
EMPLOYMENT. THIS DEFICIT WAS
MADE WORSE DUE THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE EMINEM
PART IS IDEALLY LOCATED A
HOUSING SUPPORT A VARIETY OF
ROBUST AND SUSTAINABLE BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES AND OCCUPATIONS.
ONE OF MY FOCUSES HAS BEEN ON A
LIGHT HEALTH CARE OPPORTUNITIES
DUE TO THE DEMONSTRATE A NEED
TO GET MORE OF THESE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE FIELD. AS
WE HEAR FROM PALACE
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE PUBLIC
TODAY. I HOPE TO FIND NEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO INVEST IN OUR
PEOPLE OUR ECONOMY STRENGTHEN
THEM TO WITHSTAND FUTURE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS AND BUILD A
REGION THAT WHAT THRIVE. ON THE
FIRST PANEL WILL HEAR FROM.
CHAO'S ALAMO WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
CALIFORNIA'S NONPARTISAN THINK
TANK ON BUDGET AND POLICY
ISSUES. ALSO AFTER THAT WE'LL
HAVE ERIC ROD CHIEF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS DIVISIONS OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS THE
DIVISION DELIGHT COLLABORATES
WITH EMPLOYERS TO EMPLOY A
COMMUNITY TO DEVELOP A SKILLED
WORKFORCE. ON THE SECOND PANEL
WILL HEAR FROM GEORGE.
HERMANSSON WITH FEDERAL HEALTH
FUTURE OF SERVES AS A MODEL OF
HOW THEM PORTER COMMITTEE ON
TRAINEES CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
ACHIEVE. EFFECTIVE AND CONSUMER
FOCUSED ON THE JOB TRAINING.
AND THEN WITH THAT WILL HELP-
COMMITTEE COLLEGE VICE
CHANCELLOR DAVID O'BRIEN. VICE
CHANCELLOR BRIAN OVERSEES THE
LEGISLATIVE DIVISION OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WHICH I AM
PLEASED TO WORK WITH ON THIS
YEAR ON MY BILL TO PROMOTE EARN
AND LEARN OPPORTUNITIES. BEFORE
WE BEGAN ARE THERE ANY OPENING
REMARKS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OR GAS FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE CAUCUS. GOOD. THE
LEAST MAJORITY LEADER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND THE
SPEAKER OF FOR PUTTING THIS
PARTICULAR SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING- PUTTING THIS ON TODAY
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
YOUR COMMENTS REGARDING THE
INLAND EMPIRE IT IS ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING THERE IS GREAT
NEED WE HAVE 26% OF OUR
FAMILIES LIVING BELOW THE LINE
OF POVERTY. BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE LOTS OF
BUSINESSES WE HAVE
MANUFACTURING WE HAVE SO MANY
OTHER BUSINESSES THAT ARE
WORKING VERY HARD SUMMER
THRIVING BUT THEY'RE ALL
WORKING VERY HARD AND EMPLOYING
A WORKFORCE OF ALMOST A MILLION
PEOPLE. THE WORK THAT YOU DO
HERE- MISTER CHAIR IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT I THINK IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS LEGISLATORS
TO PURSUE THOSE LEGISLATIVE
REFORMS THAT CAN CREATE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES OPPORTUNITIES
WITH PARITY AND ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY JOBS FOR ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS ESPECIALLY OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. I
WANT TO MENTION ONE OF THE TWO
TWO ITEMS ONE IS- IF THE BUDGET
ITEM THAT YOU YOU REQUESTED AND
I WAS HONORED TO JOIN YOU IN
THAT REQUEST FOR THE WELDING
PROGRAM- THE FOOD WAS A
PARTNERSHIP WITH CHAFEE COLLEGE
AND CALIFORNIA STEEL AND THAT
WAS INCLUDED IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET AND I WAS VERY PLEASED
TO JOIN YOU ON THAT AND THE
OTHER IS AB TEN SEVENTY TWO. OF
WHICH WE CO AUTHORED BREAKING
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OUR COLLEAGUE EDUARDO GARCIA
I'M EXCITED TO HEAR FROM THE
EXPERTS FROM ON THE PANELS
TODAY AND TO SEE WHAT IT IS WE
CAN DO TO HELP OUR. INLAND
EMPIRE GROW THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU MAJORITY. SO AT UP.
BUT YOUR QUESTION YET NO I JUST
GO AHEAD MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS
TO THANK FOR INCLUDING ME ON
THIS A PANEL LOOK FORWARD TO
THE DISCUSSION WITH OUR
PANELISTS. BECAUSE OF IS BEEN
MENTIONED THE INLAND EMPIRE IS
GROWING IN A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
MOVING OUT THAT WAY FOR JOBS WE
HAVE THE JOBSWE HAVE THE
EDUCATED WORK FORCE. AND WE
NEED TO KEEP THAT GOING FOR THE
INLAND EMPIRE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SO WITH THAT
LET'S BEGIN WITH CHAO'S ALAMO
REPRESENTING THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. MR ALAMO IS A
PRINCIPAL FISCAL AND POLICY
ANALYST AT THE ALLEY- WHERE HE
PROVIDES GUIDANCE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AND STATE LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT ISSUES. CHAO'S
WHEN YOU'RE READY. HI THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN CAN YOU GUYS
HEAR ME OKAY YES YEP THANK YOU
MR TRêN NUMBERS ARE ACTUALLY-
BRIAN YOU ARE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
CHAS ALAMO WELCOMED A NEW BABY
GIRL INTO HIS FAMILY THIS
MORNING SO I WILL. DO MY BEST
TO FILL IN IN HIS- PLACE- OUR
OUR OFFICE WAS ASKED TO COME IN
AND PROVIDE SOME. CONTEXT OR
TODAY'S HEARING ON FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR- EARN AND LEARN
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE STATE- AND
WE'VE- TO HELP PROVIDE THAT
CONTEXT WILL PREPARE TO HAND
OUT FOR THE COMMITTEE-
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE IT IN YOUR
AGENDA PACKET- IF NOT THE
SERGEANTS HAVE SOME COPIES-
AND- IT'S THE HAND OUT FREE TO
REFERENCE AS YOU GO THROUGH THE
HEARING. OF THE FIRST OF THREE
PAGES OF THE HAND OUT PROVIDE
JUST KIND OF A HIGH LEVEL
DESCRIPTION. OF THE KEY TYPES
OF VERNON LEARN OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE STATE AND THE STATE
AGENCIES AND PROGRAMS- THAT
CARRY OUT. THOSE LEARN
OPPORTUNITIES. AND THIS THIS
CONTEXT IS IMPORTANT FOR
THINKING ABOUT THE DIFFERENT-
FUNDING BUCKETS WHAT'S ALL
WHICH I WILL SUMMARIZE- IN IN A
FEW MINUTES- BUT BUT FIRST TO
GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND
AGENCIES- THAT OUR SUPPLIER. I
LEVEL- THERE'S A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF ART AND
LEARNED A LOT YOU KNOW WHAT
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE ANYTHING
FROM APPRENTICESHIPS AND PRE
APPRENTICESHIPS- WHICH- PROVIDE
SHORTER TERM TRAINING TO HELP-
WRITTEN REDUCED- TECHNICAL
BARRIERS- BUT PREPARE. FOLKS
THAT MIGHT HAVE OF BARRIERS TO
ENTERING A APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM- WE ALSO HAVE ENCUMBER
WORKER TRAINING PROGRAMS WHICH
ARE- TYPICALLY EMPLOYER
SPONSORED PROGRAMS- THAT THEY
PROVIDE TO THEIR CRRENT
WORKERS- TO HELP THEM LEARN A
MERGING NEW TECHNOLOGIES OR TO
PROMOTE INTO MORE ADVANCED
POSITIONS. WITHIN THE COMPANY
AS THE STATE ALSO SUPPORTS A-
SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS-
WHICH- ARE THOSE WHERE A THIRD
PARTY TYPICALLY A GOVERNMENT
AGENCY IS PROVIDING. US SOME
SOME FUNDING TO COVER WAGE
COSTS FOR CERTAIN WORKERS TO
ENCOURAGE. EMPLOYERS TO HIRE
AND RETRAIN OTHERS WORKERS. IN
TERMS OF STUDENTS THE STATE
ALSO SUPPORTS A VARIETY OF PAID
INTERNSHIP AND PAID PROJECT
BASED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES-
SO THAT'S KIND OF THE- THE
GENERAL LANDSCAPE OF THE KIND
OF THE TYPES OF EARN AND LEARN
PROGRAMMES- IN TERMS OF
THINKING ABOUT THE KEY PLAYERS
IN TERMS OF AGENCIES THAT ARE
ADMINISTERING THESE. THERE'S A
FEW KEY CATEGORIES- THE FIRST
IS THOSE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE'S
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES-
WOULD START WITH THE DIVISION
OF APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS-
WHICH AS MENTIONED IS WITHIN
THE PARMA DUST RELATIONS AND
THEY CERTIFY AND OVERSEE. ALL
OF THE OPPRESSOR PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE. WE ALSO HAVE THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL.
WHICH PROVIDES GRANTS TO
EMPLOYERS- TO FIND SHORT TERM
INCUMBENT WORKER TRAINING IN
THIS IS TYPICALLY A FINANCED
THROUGH A STATEWIDE EMPLOYEE
PAID PAYROLL TAX. FINALLY HAVE
THE ALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD WHICH SETS US
STATE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
POLICY IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
FEDERAL WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITY ACT AND FUNDING.
THE SECOND KEY CATEGORY ARE
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE'S
VARIOUS EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
ARE STARTING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE ON THIS PROGRAM
SUPPORTS NEW APPRENTICESHIP AND
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FOR
INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEEMED. HIGH DEMAND SUCH AS
HEALTH CARE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND ALSO THAT HAVE
NOT- TRADITIONALLY USED IN
APPRENTICESHIP MODEL. ON THIS
PROGRAM IS FUNDED WITH
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
DOLLARS AND IS ADMINISTERED BY
THE COMMUNITY OTHER CALIFORNIA
MANY CALLS CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THE FUNDING IS AVAILABLE TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COLLEGES
AND IS INTENDED TO SUPPORT-
CURRICULUM IN START UP COSTS
FOR PENSION PROGRAMS. ARE ALSO
UNDER THE KIND OF EDUCATIONAL
UMBRELLA WE HAVE- THE RELATED
AND SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION
PROGRAM WHICH REIMBURSES
APPRENTICESHIP SPONSORS FOR
PORTION OF THEIR INSTRUCTIONAL
COSTS AND- IN ORDER TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE
REIMBURSEMENTS THEY MUST A
PARTNER WITH A SCHOOL OR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN CARRYING
OUT THEIR PRECIOUS. FINALLY OF
THE- THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM WHICH WAS CREATED TO
IMPROVE- THE AVAILABILITY AND
QUALITY OF CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- AND USE FUNDS ARE
INTENDED SUPPORT THINGS LIKE
SMALLER TRAINING CLASS SIZES-
QUITMAN COSTS. AND REGIONAL
PLANNING COORDINATION- AND
RECENT- A RECENT FUNDING IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET-
EXPAND THIS TO INCLUDE- WORK
BASED LEARNING- PURPOSES LIKE
AN INTERNSHIP. ALL THE FINAL
BUCKET OR OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH
A HEALTHY HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCIES IN PARTICULAR- THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES A
CASH GRANTS TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN AND ONE
OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF ADULTS.
WHO ARE PARTICIPANTS IN
CHARACTERS THAT THEY EITHER BE
WORKING OR PARTICIPATE IN WORK
TRAINING. A KEY ELEMENT OF A
COW OR CAL WORKS WORK TRAINING
IS A SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM. THROUGH WHICH THE
STATE PROVIDES A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
TO PROVIDE. COVER A PORTION OF
WAGE COSTS FOR EMPLOYERS WHO
HIRE CAL WORKS. RECIPIENTS SO
KIND OF WITH HAVING LAID OUT
THAT THE LANDSCAPE OF ALL THESE
VARIOUS- PIECES OF THE- AND
LEARN PUZZLE ON PAGE FOUR- WE
OUTLINED THAT THE FUNDING TO
THESE OF VARIOUS. COMPONENTS. I
WON'T YOU KNOW WALK LINE BY
LINE HERE THROUGH THE FUNDING
FOR EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU CAN SEE HERE IT'S
SUMMARIZED. IN THE TABLE IN
PAGE FOR THE HAS THE LINE ITEM
APPROPRIATION N EACH OF THESE
AREAS AND THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. BUDGET JUST A COUPLE OF
KIND OF HIGHER LEVEL
OBSERVATION YOU'LL NOTICE HERE-
THAT THE FUNDING IS. ALLOCATED
ACROSS A VARIETY OF BUDGET LINE
ITEMS ENTITIES AND IS TARGETED
AT A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- IN TOTAL THE FUNDING. IS
ABOUT ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND THIS IS A NOTABLE
INCREASE FOR THIS- THE
SELECTION OF PROGRAMS OVER THE
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET MORE THAN
INCREASE MORE THAN A THIRD OVER
THE FUNDING LEVEL. I THAT WAS
PROVIDED PREVIOUSLY- SO WITH
THAT I'LL GO TO CONCLUDE MY
PRESENTATION- AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. OKAY THANKS BROWN IF YOU
DON'T MIND- WE HAVE- ERIC
GREITENS COME UP. FROM THE
CHIEF A CHIEF OF THE VENTURE
PARTNERSHIP STANDARDS THANK YOU
FOR APPEARING TODAY DISCUSS%
INTERNAL LEARN ALSO REFERRED TO
AS PRESSURE PROGRAMS.
OPPORTUNITIES THAT MAY BE
AVAILABLE IN THE EMPIRE AND THE
DIVISION IS DOING TO INCREASE
THESE OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
REGION. JACK CAN YOU GO AHEAD
AND ADJUST STAYS WELL TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AFTER A- ERIC
VENTURES THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
WELL GOOD- COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
THE STEAM COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS ERIC REID I AM THE
CHIEF OF THE DIVISION OF
OPPRESSIVE STANDARDS. I'M
HONORED TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIPS. HOW CAN BE A
SOLUTION TO CALIFORNIA'S
LOOMING CRISIS TO RESOLVE THE
GROWING NEED IN THE ALLIED
HEALTH WORKFORCE. AND HOW IT
CAN ADDRESS THE WORKFORCE NEEDS
FOR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS. APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS OUR COLLABORATION OF
MANY PARTNERS. MY TEAM AT THE
DIVISION OF PRINCIP STANDARDS
HELP THESE PARTNERS DEVELOPED A
FRAMEWORK FOR REGIONAL. IN
INDUSTRY APPRENTICESHIP
SPONSORS. OUR PARTNERS INCLUDE
EMPLOYERS IN THERE-
ASSOCIATIONS LABOR UNIONS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
NONPROFITS AND LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WHICH
INCLUDE. COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION'S LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. APPRENTICESHIPS ARE
JOBS APPRENTICESHIP APPRENTICES
RECEIVE AROUND A HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR HOURS A YEAR IN CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION. WHETHER IN PERSON
OR NOWADAYS A LOT OF ONLINE-
CLASSES AS WELL LEARN LEARNING
A SPECIFIC JOB CORPS FUNCTION
IN APPLYING THOSE LESSONS
LEARNED ON THE JOB. APPRENTICES
YOU REQUIRE AT LEAST ONE WAGE
PROGRESSION OR REYES AS A
PRINCIPAL LEARN NEW SKILLS
DURING THE DURATION OF THE
APPRENTICESHIP. FRIENDSHIPS CAN
LAST ANYWHERE FROM ONE TO FIVE
YEARS DEPENDING ON THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE JOB.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS PROVIDE
FOR DIVERSITY MANY OF OUR
PROGRAMS EMPHASIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN PEOPLE
OF COLOR JUSTICE IMPACTED
VETERANS. AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. TO EARN A WAGE
WHILE GETTING AN EDUCATION.
THIS MAKES APPRENTICESHIP IN
ATTRACTIVE MODEL FOR SOCIALLY
MINDED INDUSTRY PARTERS IN
MEETING ACT THEIR EQUITY GOALS.
CALIFORNIA DEPENDS ON A VAST
WELL TRAINED WORKFORCE OF
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO PROVIDE
QUALITY CARE TO THE STATE'S
DIVERSE POPULATION. ALLIED
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHICH
INCLUDE MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
DENTAL ASSISTANCE IMAGING
SPECIALISTS IN OTHER NON
NURSING PROFESSIONS MAKE UP 60%
OF THE SPECIALISTS AND OTHER
NON NURSING PROFESSIONS- IN THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. IN ARE IN
HIGH DEMAND AND SHORT SUPPLY.
CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATES IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN SUGGESTED THAT
CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND ALLIED HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS ANNUALLY
RESULTING IN A DEMAND OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW WORKERS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THIS NEED
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WHICH
TRANSLATES TO AROUND SEVENTY
THOUSAND NEW WORKERS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. TO MEET THIS NEED
CALIFORNIA MUST FIRST ASSESS
THE CURRENT SUPPLY OF ALLIED
HEALTH PROFESSIONS
PROFESSIONALS. IN THE REMOVE
KEY BARRIERS TO INCREASE IN ANY
SUPPLY SHORTAGE. ACCORDING TO A
RECENT CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATION REPORT THERE WILL BE
NEARLY. A HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
THOUSAND TO TWO HUNDRED NINETY
SIX THOUSAND UNFILLED JOBS OVER
THE EIGHT YEAR PERIOD IN THE
TEN HIGHEST DEMAND ALLIED
HEALTH PROFESSIONS
APPROXIMATELY 10% OF THAT WOULD
BE THE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
ONE WAY OF ADDRESSING THIS NEED
TO TRAIN LOWER LEVEL INCUMBENT
WORKERS IN HEALTH FACILITIES TO
CLIMB A CAREER LADDER WITHIN
THEIR INSTITUTIONS TO BE BETTER
PAID. MORE SKILLED JOBS. OTHER
BOYS TO EXPERIENCE THE GREATEST
JOB GROSS SUPPORT IN TECHNICIAN
POSITION IN ALLIED HEALTH
ESPECIALLY THOSE PROVIDING LONG
TERM CARE FACE CONSIDERABLE.
JOB QUALITY CHALLENGES. ACCESS
TO A QUALITY JOB HEAVILY
STRATIFIED BY RACE GENDER
GEOGRAPHY. AND LEVEL OF
EDUCATION ATTAINMENT IN
TRAINING. BLACK THAT NEXT IN
NEED OF AMERICAN HEALTH WORKERS
INCLUDING WORKERS FROM SPECIFIC
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER ETHNIC
GROUPS IN IMMIGRANT BACKGROUNDS
TEND TO BE CONCENTRATED IN
ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS WITH
LOWER BERRIES BARRIERS TO ENTRY
BUT WITH LOWER WAGES AND
STRESSFUL WORKING CONDITIONS.
THESE POSITIONS SUCH AS
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE AND HOME
HEALTH AIDES ARE OFTEN PART
TIME EARLY OR TEMPORARY
POSITIONS WITH LIMITED BENEFITS
AND LIMITED CAREER ADVANCEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. OVERALL
POSITIONS THAT INVOLVE FEEDING
MOVING CLEANING AND CARING FOR
PATIENTS ARE GENERALLY PART
TIME AND OFFER FEWER BENEFITS.
WORKERS IN THIS SECTORWHO ARE
PREDOMINANTLY WOMEN OF COLOR ON
AVERAGE EARN A LITTLE OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
ENOUGH TO WORK TWO OR THREE
JOBS TO MAKE ENDS MEET. GIVEN
THESE UNATTRACTIVE CONDITIONS
EMPLOYERS FACE AN UP HILL
BATTLE IN RECRUITING. AND
RETAINING WORKERS FOR THE
FASTEST GROWING POSITIONS. WELL
THE DEMAND AND JOB AVAILABILITY
ARE HIGH THESE OCCUPATIONS
EXPERIENCE THE TORIES FLEA HIGH
TURNOVER RATES WHICH CAN LEAD
TO POOR QUALITY AND FRAGMENTED
PATIENT CARE INCREASING COST TO
THE EMPLOYER. THE RATE IN WHICH
LONG TERM CARE WORKERS SUCH AS
PERSONAL CARE OR HOME HEALTH
AIDES MEDICAL SYSTEMS. OR
LICENSED VOCATIONAL NURSES
LEAVE THE PROFESSION FOR OTHER
EMPLOYMENT FAR OUTPACES THE
RATE OF ENTRY INTO THESE JOBS.
AND THOSE WHO DO LEAVE ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE UNEMPLOYED REPORT
HIGHER RATES OF DISABILITY
EXPERIENCE HIGHER RATES OF
POVERTY. ONE WAY OF ADDRESSING
THIS NEED IS CREATING THROUGH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT WILL
SUPPORT LOWER LEVEL WORKERS
EARNING A SALARY IN THEIR
CURRENT POSITIONS. WELL
TRAINING FOR HIGHER LEVEL
POSITIONS SUCHAS A THERAPIST
OR TECH POSITIONS. DIVISIONER
PRECIOUS STANDARDS HAS
SUPPORTED A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
ONE THOUSAND THAT TOOK. LICENSE
LOCATIONAL NURSES WORKING IN
FACILITIES. SUPPORTED THROUGH A
TWENTY TWENTY PROGRAM WHERE THE
EMPLOYER REQUIRED TWENTY HOURS
OF WORK. AND PROVIDED TWENTY
HOURS OF PAID TIME OFF FOR
ENROLLMENT IN THE LPN TO RN
PROGRAM. THIS ALLOWED LPNS TO
CONTINUE EARNING THEIR SALARY
WELL IN ROLLED IN THESE
TRAINING PROGRAMS. A WE HAVE
SINCE STARTED THE PROGRAM IN.
SACRAMENTO AREA AND WE ARE NOW
DOING THAT PROGRAM NOW IN
RIVERSIDE S. AS WELL. AT THE
DIVISION OF APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARD I'M SORRY ABOUT 92% OF
THE PARTICIPANTS IN THIS LPN TO
RN PROGRAM OR MINORITIES OR
RECENT IMMIGRANTS. OVER 50%
WERE SINGLE MOTHERS WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TO RETURN TO SCHOOL FOR
AN RN DEGREE. SIX US WILL
GRADUATES 90% OF THOSE ENTERING
THE PROGRAM WERE ABLE TO
INCREASE OUR WAGES FROM FORTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
TO NINETY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR. WITH A COMMITMENT FOR
TWO YEARS OF EMPLOYMENT AT THE
INSTITUTION FOLLOWING THEIR
GRADUATION. THE DIVISION OF
OPPRESSIVE STANDARDS IS NOW
LOOKING TO SUPPORT DNTAL
ASSISTANT PROGRAMS. IN OTHER
AREAS IN ALLIED HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH EASY PRE
APPRENTICESHIPS. AND
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. AT THE
DIVISION OF APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS WE'RE WORKING TO
ACHIEVE THE GOVERNOR'S SCHOOL
OF FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPRENTICESHIPS OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. AND HEALTH CARE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE PRIORITY. THE
GOVERNOR HAS ADDED- FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL WHICH
WAS DISCUSSED BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT NOW IN AN
APPRENTICESHIP. THE DIVISION-
PRECIOUS STANDARDS INTERAGENCY
COMMITTEE ON A FRENCH SUPPORTED
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
THAT STRENGTHENS APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS. WITHIN THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY BY
ADDING NEW MEMBERS TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND MAKING A
PRESSURE PROGRAMS MORE SENSIBLE
TO LOW INCOME EMPLOYEES. THIS
BILL FOLLOWS EARLIER
LEGISLATION THAT ESTABLISHED
THE INTERAGENCY ADVISER CAN
COMMITTEE ON APPRENTICESHIP
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY FIVE
WHICH IS AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. IT IMPLIED MET
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE OH
FIVE ALSO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ- TASK FORCE REPORT ON
BARRIERS. AND RECOMMENDATIONS
TO FACILITATE AND EARN AND
LEARN TRAINING PROGRAMS IN
ALLIED HEALTH PROFESSIONS THAT
WAS RELEASED IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY. ONE OF THE
FINDINGS WAS THAT THE
INTERAGENCY ADVISORY COMMITTEE
ON OPPRESSION APPRENTICESHIP
WAS NOT STRUCTURE TO ALLOW FOR
THAN NECESSARY COLLABORATION
BETWEEN STATE AGENCIES.
PARTICULARLY IN THE HEALTH
FIELD SO THAT CROSS GOVERNMENT
COLLABORATION COULD BE REALIZED.
IT WAS FOUND THAT SOME OF
LICENSURE PROGRAMS LIKE
RESPIRATORY THERAPY AND
RADIOLOGIC SHE- TECHNOLOGY DO
NOT ALLOW STUDENTS TO WORK WELL
IN SCHOOL THAT'S MAKING THEM
INELIGIBLE FOR STATE
APPRENTICESHIP REGISTRATION.
AND THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THE
GOVERNOR HAS PUT IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET. WE ARE
HOPING THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE WILL REMOVE
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS TO SUCCESS.
SUCH AS REQUIREMENT BY A
PRIVATE ACCREDITING GROUPS THAT
DISALLOW FRIENDSHIP PROGRAMS
AND HEALTH CARE. THROUGH
REMOVAL OF THESE BARRIERS AND
NEW FUNDING AVAILABILITY WE CAN
CREATE A MORE DIVERSE ECONOMIC
UPWARD MOBILE WORKFORCE NOW
LIKE HEALTH. THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU WITH THAT- VERY VERY
INFORMATIVE I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION ONLY BECAUSE WE HAVE.
A COUPLE AS WELL WE TALKED
ABOUT THE HEALTH CARE PRESSURE
PROGRAMS NOT THE STATE- WOULD
ANYBODY BRIAN OR YOU ERIC KNOW
HOW MANY WE'VE DONE IN THE
WHOLE STATE AND HOW MANY OF
THOSE. ARE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND WE TALK ABOUT THE SCHOOL
RIVERSIDE BUT- DO WE KNOW
PARTICULAR IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
HOW MANY OF THOSE- PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE OUT THERE ARE
STUDENTS IN THE PRESSURE
PROGRAM. YEAH WE'VE BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD IN THE
LAST. THREE YEARS TO REALLY
FOCUS ON NOT WHAT WE WERE CUT
NONTRADITIONAL REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIPS THESE ARE FOR
PROJECTS OUTSIDE OF THE
TRADITIONAL CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. IN FIREFIGHTING WHICH
IT WHICH MAKES UP ABOUT 90% OF
ALL OF REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIPS- WE HAVE
DEVELOP SOME PROGRAMS WITH- THE
SURELY WHERE EDUCATION FUND
WHICH IS- MADE UP THAT'S A
JOINT APPRENTICESHIP COMMITTEE
WITH SEIU UNITED HEALTH WORKERS
AND WITH AND WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE AA ANTIGONE THE
HEALTH ON. ABOUT FIVE
DIFFERENCE- ALLIED HEALTH
CLASSIFICATIONS ARE THESE ARE
STATEWIDE- BUT THE NUMBERS ARE
REALLY SMALL- BECAUSE A LOT OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE-
OUR OVERALL HEALTH CARE
NUMBERS- WOULD BE LESS THAN
FIVE HUNDRED REGISTER PRINCES
STATEWIDE AND WITH THAT SET UP-
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT PROP TEN PERCENT.
OF THAT NUMBER. BAKER THANK
YOU- AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
JUST WISH COME BECAUSE OUT OF
THE WHOLE PACKAGE IS ONE TO BE
DOLLARS OF THAT I THINK BRIAN
MENTIONED SO WE CAN IT-
ESTIMATE 10% OF THE GO TO THE
INLAND EMPIRE- THE FUNNY IT'S A
LITTLE BIT. TRICKY FOR ME AS A
DIVISION OF PRISM STANDARDS
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT CONTROL OF
THE FUNDING DOLLARS. SO FOR
THAT I THINK PROBABLY I'LL I'LL
LET THE L. A. L. SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY. YEAH I DON'T
THERE ISN'T ANY- SPECIFIED
REGIONAL DISTRIBUTION OF THE
FUNDING SO I THINK THE 10%
AMOUNT IS KIND OF ROUGHLY THE
SHARE OF THE STATE'S WORKFORCE
AND POPULATION THAT'S IN THE IN
THE EMPIRE- BUT NO THERE IS NO-
THERE ISN'T ANY PARTICULAR
REGIONAL DISTRIBUTION OF MOST
OF THOSE FUNDS AND AN
APPRENTICESHIP CAN I GET OUT OF
FUNDING THROUGH. BOTH EIGHTY
DAYS OR THE WORK FORCE
DEVELOPMENT OR I CAN ONLY GET
ONE SOURCE OF FUNDING FROM ONE
GOVERNMENT AGENCY. THE SERVICE
SO THE PRIVATE DIVISION
OPPRESSION STANDARDS WHEN WE
PUT TO WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS
WELL WITH HIM EMPLOYERS
EMPLOYER. ASSOCIATIONS WITH
WITH LABOR PARTNERS WITH- WITH
OUR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
WE LOOK AT- SOURCES OF FUNDING
THAT COULD BE- WHAT WE WOULD
CALL- BRAIDED SO YOU COULD HAVE
MORE THAN ONE SOURCE OF
FUNDING. REALLY LOOKING AT
SPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT DISADVANTAGED POPULATIONS
MAKING SURE THAT- THEY
POTENTIALLY COULD HAVE ACCESS
WITH WORKFORCE INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITY DOLLARS THROUGH A
LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARD- WE JUST
RECENTLY LAUNCHED- SOMEWHAT
HEALTH CARE RELATED. A HUGE
INLAND EMPIRE CYBERSECURITY
CONSORTIUM. IN CYBER SECURITY.
AND ONE OF OUR KEY EMPLOYERS IS
LOW MULLIN TO HEALTH. I'M
REALLY LOOKING AT SPECIFICALLY
TARGETING THE CYBER SECURITY
NEEDS IN THE HOSPITAL SETTING.
AND AND SO THE INLAND EMPIRE IS
ONE OF THE REGIONS IN THE STATE
THAT WERE REALLY ARE TARGETING
BECAUSE WE WANT TO KEEP- THE
TALENT IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT THERE IS
A PREMIER INSTITUTION IN CSU
SAMBAR TO DINO- THAT HAS A
GLOBAL IMPACT. IN THEIR
CYBERSECURITY PROGRAM. HOWEVER
ALTHOUGH 75% OF THEIR STUDENTS
WERE COMING FROM LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES INTO CSU
SAMBAR TO DINO. VERY FEW WERE
ABLE TO STAY AT HOME AND SO
ENDED UP IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY LIKE PALO ALTO- IN IN-
VIRGINIA- IN IN OTHER AREAS
WHERE THERE'S A CYBER SECURITY
NEED. AND SO THIS CONSORTIUM
WAS REALLY TO TRY TO KEEP- THE
BRAIN TALENT YET HOME. AND
PROVIDE QUALITY JOBS YEAH IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE IN SO WE HAD
EMPLOYER SAID INCLUDED AS
THREE- WHICH IS- NATIONAL
DEFENSE CONTRACTOR AND REDLANDS-
WE HAD- CONVERGE ONE WE HAVE
ROB HALF INTERNATIONAL- SO
THERE'S A BIG FOCUS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE- FOR US TO REALLY
GROW APPRENTICESHIPS. AND WORK
ACTUALLY MODELING. THE INLAND
EMPIRE WAS THE FIRST ON THE
CYBERSECURITY CONSORTIUM. WE'RE
NOW TRYING TO MODEL THAT IN
OTHER PARTS OF STATE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE WORKING LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTY IS TO DO THE SAME
THANK YOU. AND THEN ONE MORE
QUESTION IS THERE ANY WAY AS US
LEGISLATORS CAN HELP YOU
STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR
REGISTERING THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS. YEAH SO IT IT IT
APPRENTICESHIP OR IS REALLY
REQUIRES- REALLY EMPLOYERS TO
REALLY HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME TO
REALLY DEVELOP THEIR WORKFORCE-
THERE IS A BIG NEED. FOR
EMPLOYERS TO GET QUALITY. OF
WORKERS. AND SO. RIGHT NOW
APPRENTICESHIP IS BEEN- WE'VE
HAD MORE RECEPTION TO
DEVELOPING REGISTERED
APPRENTICES IN THESE
NONTRADITIONAL AREAS- OVER THE
LAST. TWO TO THREE YEARS IN A
LOT OF THAT IS BECAUSE OF. THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE ASSEMBLY IN
PARTICULAR- PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE FUNDING.
AND MORE OR MORE OPPORTUNITIES
AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO
DEVELOPING AN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND PART OF THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
REQUIRES- IN ADMINISTRATIVE
PIECE- I KNOW THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- COMMISERATING SABETTA
TALKED ABOUT- **** CHAFEE
COLLEGE AND WHAT THEY'VE DONE
WITH CALIFORNIA'S STEEL- THAT
WAS A PROGRAM THAT WE DEVELOPED
ABOUT THREE FOUR YEARS AGO AS
WELL- THE KEY FOR US. IS REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT THEIR
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING. TO THESE
PROGRAMS THAT WILL SERVE MULTI
EMPLOYERS. AND SERVE ACROSS-
YOU KNOW THAT WE CONNECT SCALE
THESE PROGRAMS UP SO WE'RE NOT
SERVING JUST YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE YOU KNOW THE
APPRENTICES IN A COHORT BUT
LOOKING AT WAYS THAT WE CAN-
INCREASE THE NUMBERS INTO LIKE
THE THOUSANDS- THROUGH. YOU
KNOW ONE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM- I DO WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT JUST REAL QUICK ON
UP ON A- ON A PROGRAM THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON RIGHT NOW IT'S
IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL CSE-
FACES- WITH THE CVS- ART WITH
SPECIFICALLY- WE'RE WORKING TO
DO DUAL. COMPENSATE BASED
STANDARDS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR IN THE DIVISION OF FRESH
OF STANDARDS FOR THE HEALTH
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN.
CLASSIFICATION CVS OPERATES
ABOUT NINE REGIONS WITH ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
STORES THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
THE INTENTION TO HAVE. TEN
APPRENTICES IN THE FIRST COHORT.
YEAH THE INLAND EMPIRE- USUALLY
THE PLAN TO HIRE. A NEW WORKER
SO AND NOT INCOME IT WORKERS
BUT AT SOME POINT WILL OFFER
PRECIOUS OPPORTUNITIES TO THEIR
EXISTING WORKFORCE. THEY ARE
COMMITTED TO ADDING TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED JOBS THROUGH THEIR
PRESSURE PROGRAM BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SO YOU CAN START
SEEING SCALABILITY. AND
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
REGISTER PRINCES BY TEN
THOUSAND OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS- THROUGHOUT THE
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. I SEE
SEE THIS IS ALSO IN DEVELOPMENT
A STATE REGISTERED PRE
APPRENTICESHIP SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY PROVIDE PATHWAYS- FOR
OUR DISADVANTAGED POPULATION SO
THAT'S THAT'S A AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT WE WANT TO ACCOMPLISH IS
TO. DEVELOP THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WHERE WE CAN SERVE LARGE
NUMBERS- OF- INLAND EMPIRE
RESIDENTS. THANK YOU DELIVER.
WHICH RETURN. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. OF ONE OF THE
STATISTICS THAT WE'VE HEARD OF
SINCE ESPECIALLY SINCE KOBE IS
THE IMPACT- UNEMPLOYMENT IS HAD
ON PEOPLE OF COLOR AND WOMEN
PARTICULARLY AND LATINOS VERY
SPECIFICALLY YEAH- IT THE
STATISTICS I'VE SEEN SHOW THAT
THEY ARE THE MOST IMPACTED ON
THE COME FROM THE LOW WAGE-
JOBS ALSO AND I'M OFF TO THE
SOLE PROVIDERS OF THEIR FAMILY.
WHAT CAN WE AS LEGISLATORS DUE
TO SUPPORT ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES PARTICULARLY FOR
WOMEN AND PARTICULARLY FOR
WOMEN OF COLOR YEAH GREAT
QUESTION AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT DOES KEEP ME UP AT
NIGHT WE ACTUALLY DO A REALLY
GOOD JOB IN AN APPRENTICESHIP
FOR HITTING AT THE CITY. WHAT
WE DON'T DO A GOOD JOB IS THE
GENDER AND HISTORICALLY MOST OF
OUR REGISTERED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN IN
CONSTRUCTION AND FIREFIGHTING
WHICH HAVE BEEN TRADITIONALLY
MALE DOMINATED- PROFESSIONS ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I REALLY AM
EXCITED ABOUT IS THAT WHEN WE
START DEVELOPING CAREERS IN
HEALTH CARE- AND IN OTHER
PROFESSIONS AND YOU KNOW WHITE
COLLAR OR BLUE COLLAR
PROFESSIONS- BECAUSE WE CAN TO
DEVELOP APPRENTICESHIPS. IT OCT.
THAT COULD BE ACCOUNTING OR OR-
YOU KNOW IT YOU KNOW ALL
DIFFERENT TYPES OF FINANCE
MARKETING- ENGINEERING. AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WERE REALLY
LOOKING AT IS HOW DO WE REALLY
AFFECT WOMEN IN THEM WOMEN OF
COLOR IN PARTICULAR- ACROSS ALL
OF OUR REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS- WOMEN
REPRESENT ABOUT SEVEN PERCENT.
OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
APPRENTICES AND WE HAVE ABOUT
NINETY ONE THOUSAND. TWO
HUNDRED OR SO REGISTER PREMISES
TODAY THAT ARE ACTIVE- WE GET
INTO THE CONSTRUCTION OF
FIREFIGHTERS IN OUR SALUTE
SHAME IT'S AN ABSOLUTE SHAME I
WILL TELL YOU IF I MAY GO THAT
OFTEN TIMES THINGS HAPPEN AND
WE THINK WELL IT'S JUST THAT
THERE ISN'T AN INTEREST. IF WE
NOT ARE NOT INTENTIONAL ABOUT
WHAT WE DO IT WILL NEVER BE
CORRECTED. IT HAS TO BE
INTENTIONAL AND IF IT MEANS
SAYING THAT A PERCENTAGE HAVE
TO BE WOMEN OR YOU START
LOOKING AT. APPRENTICESHIPS
APPRENTICESHIPS ARE FOR JOBS
WE'RE MORE WOMEN WILL BE
INTERESTED ARE DOING MORE
OUTREACH SO THAT YOU HAVE THAT
DIVERSITY SPECIFICALLY GENDER
DIVERSITY. IF IT IS NOT
INTENTIONAL I GUARANTEE YOU IT
WILL NEVER HAPPEN YEAH. SO IF
WE RECOGNIZE THAT LESS THAN 10%
OF THE APPRENTICESHIP
APPRENTICESHIPS ARE WOMEN YEAH.
THEN WE KNOW SOMETHING HAS TO
BE DONE SPECIFICALLY TO
INCREASE THOSE NUMBERS BECAUSE
THAT ISN'T THAT IS MONEY FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S
NOT GOING TO PEOPLE WHO LOOK
LIKE ME. THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE GOING TO EVERYBODY
OTHER THAN TO THE ONES THAT
LOOK LIKE ME AND THAT THAT IS
AN- ABSOLUTE SHAME AND I HOPE
THAT THERE WILL BE SOMETHING.
TO CHANGE THAT YEAH THAT THAT
IT AND AGAIN THE WORD IS
INTENTIONALITY YEAH IF YOU ARE
NOT INTENTIONAL ABOUT CHANGING
IT IT WILL NOT CHANGE. AND
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES IN THAT
MONEY NEEDS TO GO TO ALSO
PROVIDE THE APPRENTICESHIPS FOR
THE WOMEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
NOT EVEN WOMEN OF COLOR IT'S
JUST WOMEN IN GENERAL WOMEN
GENERAL AND I WILL SAY ABOUT
25% OF WOMEN ARE IN OUR
NONTRADITIONAL FRIENDSHIP WHICH
IS STILL NOT- YOU KNOW
SOMETHING. IT THAT IS A
CHALLENGE RIGHT- WE HAVE. OVER
THE YEARS OUR OUR PROGRAMS HAVE
TARGETED AS MUCH SAY CAN WE DO
HAVE SOME LIMITATIONS OF
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE THAT'S
BEEN SOME OF OUR CHALLENGES.
AND BEING ABLE TO CALL OUT
SPECIFIC ETHNICITY AND- GENDER
OF REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
A CHALLENGE FOR- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO IT AGAIN YOU KNOW
TO. PROMOTE SPECIFICALLY
TARGETED- YOU KNOW GENDERS ARE
OR WHAT HAVE YOU SO. I HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THIS IS THIS
IS IMPORTANT NOT TALKING ABOUT
QUOTAS NOT NOT GETTING ABOUT
BEING INTENTIONAL ABOUT WHAT WE
DO RIGHT AND IF YOU HAVE LESS
THAN TEN PERCENT. WHO ARE WOMEN
YOU ARE FAILING HIM BECAUSE YOU
ARE NOT SERVING THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. 50% OF THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA IS
WOMEN. AND IF WE LOOK AT IF WE
LOOK AT RACIAL DIFFERENCES THEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT 60% OF THE
POPULATION BEING LATINO. AND IF
WOMEN AND LATINOS IN PARTICULAR
ARE NOT BEING INCLUDED WE ARE
FAILING. AND IF IT ISN'T
UNUSUAL PROP TWO OH NINE THAT'S
NOT THE ISSUE AND IF YOU THINK
THAT IS THE ISSUE THEN YOU NEED
TO GET A LEGAL OPINION SO THAT
YOU CAN FIGURE OUT HOW YOU CAN
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE. THOSE WHO
ARE BEING EXCLUDED BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE NOT INCLUDING THEM YOU
ARE DOING SOMETHING THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDING THEM
THAT IS ILLEGAL ALSO. SO YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT PROP TWO
NINE AND BEING WITHIN THE
BOUNDS OF THAT FIGURE OUT TO
GET THE LEGAL OPINION SO THAT
YOU CAN FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY
BECAUSE IN THE END WE HAVE A
GREAT SERVICE APPRENTICESHIPS.
YEAH AND WE'VE GOT TO BE FAIR
WITH EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA
AND HALF THE POPULATION IS
WOMEN YEAH AND WE'VE GOT TO
FIND WAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY FEEL THAT THEY ARE BEING
INCLUDED SO MAYBE IT'S WHO'S
TEACHING THEM. MAYBE IT'S WHO
IS GOING OUT TO RECRUIT MAYBE
IT'S ABOUT WHERE YOU'RE
RECRUITING BUT SOMETHING IS
WRONG THERE IS AN ABSOLUTE
DISCONNECT AND I DON'T
APOLOGIZE FOR MY PASSION ON THE
ISSUE BECAUSE IT IS SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS TO BE CORRECTED. IT
IS A DISSERVICE TO THE WOMEN
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT IS A
LOT THE NIGHT DOES A DISSERVICE
TO LET THE NOSE VERY
SPECIFICALLY. SO I HOPE
SOMETHING WILL BE DONE. VERY
INTENTIONALLY. WHAT THE BOUNDS
OF THE LAW I'M ASKING YOU TO DO
SOMETHING THAT IS ILLEGAL OR IS
AGAINST THE LAW. I'M ASKING YOU
TO SEEK LEGAL OPINION. ABOUT
HOW IT CAN BE DONE BECAUSE IT
CAN BE DONE YEAH AND WE DO
VIGOROUSLY. YOU HOW AT FROM A
STATE POLICY RICK YOU KNOW HAVE-
RECRUIT FOR WOMEN INTO THESE
PROGRAMS. AT THE END OF THE DAY
WORK WE'RE DEALING WITH
EMPLOYERS THAT- ARE DEALING
WITH THEIR INCOME A LOT OF
TIMES ARE REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIPS WHEN THEY FIRST
GET STARTED ARE USING THEIR
INCOME BUT WORKERS-
APPRENTICESHIP IS NOT REQUIRED.
BY ANY ANYBODY OTHER THAN
CONTRACTORS WORKING ON PUBLIC
WORKS. SO REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP IS VOLUNTARY AND
MANY OF THE EMPLOYERS HAVE TOLD
US. THAT THE THAT. IT'S A
CHALLENGE FOR THEM TO GO UNDER
A REGISTERED APPRENTICESHIP
MODEL BECAUSE OF THE RULES THEY
SEE IT AS A LOT OF TIMES A-
REQUIREMENT FOR LABOR UNIONS
THEY ALSO SEE IT AS- OF.
VOLUNTARILY BEING- REGULATED BY
THE STATE IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO THAT'S PART OF
OUR CHALLENGES AS WELL IS THAT
WE'RE WE'RE DEALING WITH ACTUAL
EMPLOYERS- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES A MUCH BETTER
JOB WITH OUR OWN WORKFORCE- AND
OUR PARTICIPATIONS ARE MUCH
HIGHER FOR WOMEN CLOSER TO THE
50% RATE. BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR PASSION BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE. AND AND MY PASSION IS
TO ACTUALLY SEE REGISTERED
APPRENTICES TO YOU KNOW MEET
YOU KNOW A 50% GENDER- RATES-
BECAUSE IT WOMEN REPRESENT 50%
OF THE WORKFORCE SO THANK YOU.
SO THAT CAN I ASK A DIFFERENT
AREA FUNDING STRUCTURE ON HOW
YOU WOULD TIME. I THINK WE'RE
WITH ON. YEAH WELL HE WAS HAVE.
WITH A CHANCE. AND WAREHOUSE.
AND THAT'S OF THE LARGEST
INDUSTRIES AND GROWING
INDUSTRIES IN STAMINA DINO AREA
EMPLOYING ABOUT NINE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS YEAH. WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE ECONOMIC
VITALITY IN OUR AREA. BUT WE-ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE HEALTH OF
THE RESIDENTS OF SAMBAR TO
DINO. AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT I THINK NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED SO HOW CAN WE BEST
WALK THE LINE IS SUPPORTING.
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. OF
OUR WORD AND WE'LL JUST AND TO
THE GOODS MOVEMENT. YEAH
BALANCING THAT THE HEALTH THE
TREE AND- THAT'S A GREAT FOR US
AT YOU KNOW I I'M A PART OF THE
LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AND THE THREE THERE'S
THREE TENANTS THAT WE WERE THAT
WE REALLY LOOK AT QUALITY JOBS.
IN ORDER THESE JOBS THAT ARE.
IT PAYING JOBS THAT ALLOW-
WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
THEIR FAMILIES. SECOND WE LOOK
FOR. YOU KNOW IS OR IN EQUITY
PIECE AND THEN GETS BACK TO
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT- OUR
FRIENDSHIPS REFLECT THE
COMMUNITY THAT. WE SERVE. AND
THEN FINALLY IS LOOKING AT YOU
KNOW AS A AS WE TRANSITION TO A
CLIMATE FRIENDLY- YOU KNOW
FOSSEL FREE ENVIRONMENT OVER
THE NEXT YOU KNOW FIFTEEN YEARS
OR SO- HOW DO WE GET- IT JUST
TRANSITION BUT INTO INTO GOOD.
QUALITY JOBS OF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY- WHEN WE LOOK AT
LOGISTICS AND TRANSPORTATION SO
WE LOOK AT LOOKING AT OF
PROFESSIONS THAT HAVE A WORKER
VOICE. FOR HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS LOOKING AT HOW WE
CAN REALLY- ABOUT- INDUSTRY
THAT'S GOING TO AGAIN LEAD TO.
GOOD CAREERS BUT ALSO- LOOKING
FOR JOBS OF THE FUTURE THAT
WILL ALLOW FOR- EIGHT YOU KNOW
I JUST TRANSITION AS WE MOVE
INTO IT AGAIN- CLIMB MITIGATION
TYPE OF STRATEGIES THAT WERE
EMPLOYED SO- WHEN WE LOOK AT
LOGISTICS A LOT OF WITH THE
WORKING WITH LABOR MANAGEMENT.
UNIONS TO ENSURE THAT AND
WORKERS ARE GETTING A GOOD WAGE
AND BENEFITS. AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S GOING TO BE A KEY FOR
US. AS WE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH REGISTERED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS IN THAT AREA. SO WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH- YOU KNOW
GROUPS LIKE THE TEAMSTERS AND
OTHERS THAT MAY BE INVOLVED IN
THE LOGISTICS PART- IN THE
WAREHOUSE SIDE OF THE HOUSE.
THERE HAS BEEN- AREAS WHERE A
LOT OF THESE JOBS ARE LOW
PAYING JOBS AND AT TIMES- WHERE
WORKERS GET TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
WITH WAGE THEFT AND OUR
COUNTERPARTS AT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE WOULD BE
PROBABLY BETTER SERVE TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE- WITH
WAREHOUSE- EMPLOYEES AND SO I
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF- LEGISLATION- OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS TO REALLY ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. BRIAN TELL TO TELL CHAO'S
WE'RE VERY HAPPY FOR HIM AND-
CONGRATULATIONS ON THIS BABY- I
JUST HAVE ONE LAST QUESTION FOR
ME ONE- MISTRUTH IN CREATING WE
TALK ABOUT THE EARLIER PROGRAMS
HOW COULD WE GET A BALANCE
GETTING TRAINEES EXPERIENCE
THEY NEED WHILE ALSO ENSURING
PLACEMENT SITES ARE GAINING
VALUE AND TRAINEES ARE NOT
OVERSTEPPING THEIR ABILITIES.
YEAH SO I MEAN THE B. REALLY
BUILDING UP REGISTER PRESSURE
PROGRAM START WITH- REALLY
UNDERSTANDING THE NEEDS OF
INDUSTRY AND THEIR ASSOCIATIONS
OF WHAT THE JOB IS GOING TO
ENTAIL. IT'S INSURING THAT
THEIR SUCCESSES THROUGH PRE
APPRENTICESHIPS THAT THEY'RE
GETTING THE TRAINING THAT WILL
MAKE THEM SUCCESSFUL AS THEY
ENTER INTO THE JOB MARKET- IN A
LOT OF APPRENTICESHIPS OR MAYBE
A REQIREMENT FOR. FOR
ADDITIONAL MATHEMATICAL SKILLS
AND SO DID. THE PRE
APPRENTICESHIPS REALLY SERVE TO
REALLY- PROVIDE A
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THEM TO
GAIN- WHAT WE WOULD CALL- SOFT
SKILLS OR SKILLS THAT ALLOW
THEM TO BE ABLE TO INTERVIEW
WELL AS WELL AS- YOU KNOW BE
ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL NOT ON
THE JOB SO- THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM STANDARDS ARE THE- ARE
THE VEHICLE THAT KIND OF. WILL
OUTLINE THE CROSSWALK OF THE OF
THE OF THE- WORK PROCESSES THAT
WILL BE NEEDED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. IN A REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. AND IN
THE COURSE THE INVOLVEMENT OF
THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY TO
ENSURE THAT THE QUALITY-
THERE'S QUALITY IN THE
CURRICULUM AS WE AS WE BUILD
THESE. AVERAGE DEPARTURE
PROGRAM SELF OKAY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS IF NOT WE'LL GO ON TO
OUR NEXT. ALSO THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON MISTER ROUTE FOR OUR
BEING HERE TODAY APPRECIATE
THAT AND- NOW WE MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT TOWN. NO LIKE TO INVITE
MISS HANDS HERMANSSON ADVICE
JONES OR BRIAN UP FOR SECOND
PANEL.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME DRYER HERMANSSON
DIRECTOR OF INNOVATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH FUTURE HEALTH.
RITUAL BEGAN IN CALIFORNIA HAS
GROWN ACROSS THE NATION AS A
PREMIER ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS THE GROWTH OF EARNERS
LEARN MODELS WELCOME IS ARMS
AND MISS HERMANSSON I'M PLEASED
THAT WE HAVE HERE TO SHARE YOUR
SUCCESSES AND DISCUSS. HOW WE
CAN EFFECTIVELY PROMOTE EARN A
LUMP OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE SO WHEN YOU'RE
READY. BUTTON DOWN THERE YOU GO.
AFTER CHAIR A ESTEEMED
COMMITTEE MY AND- AS DIRECTOR
OF INNOVATIVE PARTNER F. TO A
WHOLE I'M PRETTY HUMBLED AND TO
YOU TODAY. MY BACKGROUND.
ASSEMBLY IS IN PRIVATE INDUSTRY
IN HUMAN RESOURCES AND
OPERATIONS I HAVE SPENT DECADES
LOOKING FOR THE BEST PEOPLE
EVER. I ALSO I'M A LONG TIME
FACULTY MEMBER AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN BUSINESS AND IN
CAREER TECHNOLOGY TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. AND MY LAST ROLE
PRIOR TO THIS WAS AS STATEWIDE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WORKFORCE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT DIVISION
IN RETAIL HOSPITALITY TOURISM.
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF WORKING.
I KNOW YOU ALL KNOW THIS IS THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. AND THE CALIFORNIA CAN
YOU CALL IT SYSTEM IS THE LAW
PLANET'S LARGEST COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM AND I WILL SAY
WITH A TRUE PRIDE THAT THE
INLAND EMPIRE IS ONE OF THE
MOST INNOVATIVE REGIONS IN THE
STATE. I ACTUALLY BEFORE I LEFT
WAS ABLE TO- LAUNCH A VIRTUAL
MARKETING INTERNSHIP THAT TIDE
BARSTOW AND COPPER MOUNTAIN
COLLEGE- WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE REGION TO
PILOT- SOCIAL MEDIA AND DIGITAL
ANALYTICS SKILLS. FOR STUDENTS
TO HELP SMALL BUSINESSES THIS
IS ONE THAT- IS JUST THE
BEGINNING OF JUST ONE EXAMPLE I
YOU'VE MENTIONED CHAFEE. THERE
ARE SEVERAL OTHER PROGRAMS AS
WELL OBVIOUSLY BUT- I WILL AS
YOU CAN TELL I HAVE GREAT PRIDE
AS BOTH FACULTY MEMBER AS WELL
AS SOMEONE WHO IS OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
TABLE ON BOTH SIDES. SOI'M
VERY VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE
WITH YOU I'VE BUILT MANY
NUMEROUS- EMPLOYER STUDENT
PARTNERSHIPS INTERNSHIPS AND
APPRENTICESHIPS. I FEEL LIKE
THE TIME IS RIGHT FOR US TO
REALLY MAKE THESE
APPRENTICESHIPS- MAKE
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE. I'M HERE
TODAY TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT FOR TORO HEALTH AND HOW
WE HOPE TO PARTNER. ACROSS THE
STATE TO MAKE ALL OF THIS
CHANGE A REAL. FEDERAL HEALTH
AS YOU MAY KNOW WAS ESTABLISHED
IT'S A NONPROFIT. A UNIQUE
NONPROFIT ESTABLISHED WITH THE
COMMITMENT OF A HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS BY AN EMPLOYER.
KAISER PERMANENT SAY AND THE
SEIU UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS
WEST A HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
STRONG. YOU MUST KNOW A PROBLEM
TO BE SOLVED UNIQUELY WHEN A
UNION AND THE- EMPLOYER WORK
TOGETHER TRUE. AND SO OUR JOB
AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM MISTER
RICHARD THAT- FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EMPLOYER EMPLOYEES
ALONE IN CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND WE'VE HEARD
THAT THIS BIG NUMBERS IN YOUR
REGION AS WELL. OUR MISSION IS
TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND
WEALTH OF COMMUNITIES BY GOING
THE LARGEST NETWORK OF
CREDENTIALED ALLIED HEALTH
WORKERS STARTING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND CREATING A
MODEL. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH A
DIVERSE ECOSYSTEM WE BUILD A
PATH FOR STUDENT SUCCESS. FROM
AWARENESS OF THESE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES TO RECRUITMENT
TRAINING WORK BASED LEARNING
EXPERIENCES WHICH WE HOPE WILL
BE MORE APPRENTICESHIPS. IN AN
ALLIED HEALTH PROFESSION.
EMPLOYERS FROM HOSPITAL AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM ARE AMONG
THE EMPLOYER ADVISORS TO INFORM
OUR ANNUAL TRAINING ROAD MAP.
FUTURE HEALTH SUPPORTS
APPRENTICESHIP INITIATIVES TO
FULFILL OUR GOAL OF TRAINING
CREDENTIALING AND PLACING AN
EMPLOYMENT TEN THOUSAND ALLIED
HEALTH WORKERS. YOU SHOULD KNOW
THAT FOR SURE- HEALTH STARTED
IN JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY.
THREE MONTHS. LATER THE WORLD
SHUT DOWN AND YET WE WERE ABLE
TO TRAIN FIFTY OVER FIFTY
SIXTEEN HUNDRED EMPLOYEES-
START SIXTEEN HUNDRED WORKERS
IN THAT FIRST YEAR WE ARE ON
TRACK TO TRAIN THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED. THESE ARE TRAININGS
THAT BECAUSE OF OUR FUNDING
GENEROUS FUNDING FROM THESE
AMAZING PARTNERS. HAVE ZERO
TUITION BARRIER FOR THE PEOPLE
IN THE PROGRAMS WE HAVE
SCHOLARSHIP THEM ALL. I
APPRECIATE THE PASSION THAT-
COMMITTEE MEMBER GóMEZ REYES
WAS SHARING. WE ADVERTORIALS
ARE INTENTIONAL IN WHAT WE DO
WE PLAN TO DO THIS IN A WAY
THAT IS INCLUSIVE. AGILE IN
THAT IT MEETS WORKERS WHERE
THEY CAN BE NOT IN A CLASSROOM
FOR TO SAY NOT. AT UPSET HOURS
BUT- ONLINE ND HYBRID MODELS
AND ALSO THAT WE CAN LEARN HOW
TO DO THIS TO SCALE IT. AND OUR
TIME IS RUNNING OUT TO DO THESE
THINGS SO WE HAVE URGENCY ABOUT
DOING THIS. WE ALREADY HAVE A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD FOR SERVING
DIVERSE STUDENTS AND THEIR
NEEDS. IN JUST TWENTY MONTHS
SINCE WE LAUNCHED FUTURE HEALTH
IS ALREADY CREATED THESE
OPPORTUNITIES AS I MENTIONED TO
OVER FOUR THOUSAND ADULTS. TO
OBTAIN THEIR HEALTHCARE
CREDENTIAL. WE WORK WITH
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR EDUCATIONAL STUDENT
JOURNEY. IN INDUSTRY VALUED
CREDENTIALS OUR STUDENT
POPULATION LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT OUR DEMOGRAPHICS- 70%
FEMALE. I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA
SNAP ON ONE YOU GO. ANSWERED
OUR OUR OUR BACK OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE VERY ETHNICALLY
DIVERSE 46% LATIN ACTS 21%
BLACK AFRICAN AMERICAN 11%
WHITE 12% ASIAN 10% OTHERS OUR
AVERAGE AGE IS THIRTY. SAYS YOU
SAW FROM THE HANDOUT THAT I
GAVE YOU THESE ARE WORKING
ADULTS WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO NOT
WORK. I WILL ALSO SAY THAT-
THANK YOU SEE OUR- OVER A THIRD
ARE BILINGUAL AND THAT'S IN
MULTI LANGUAGES. ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'RE MOST PROUD OF IS
OUR OUTREACH AND RECRUITMENT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HEALTH CARE
EQUITY HERE AND SO FOLKS NEED
ACCESS TO BOTH THE JOBS AS WELL
AS TO UNDERSTANDING WHY THIS IS
VALUABLE TO THEM. WE ARE VERY.
PROUD OF OUR CONNECTION WITH
THE S. C. I. U. U. H. W. WHO IS
OUR ARGEST RECRUITER WE ALSO
WORK WITH OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND EDUCATION PROVIDERS
WE PROVIDE INFORMATIONAL
SYSTEM. INFORMATIONS SESSIONS
PRE STUDENT ORIENTATIONS WE
ALSO TRY ARE TRYING NEW WAYS TO
TALK TO PEOPLE BECAUSE NOT
EVERYBODY READS THE PAPER OR
READ AN EMAIL A LOT OF PEOPLE
LOOK AT THEIR PHONE AND SO THEY
HAS TO COME FROM TRUSTED
RESOURCES- REFERRAL PROGRAMS-
AND COUNTY WORKFORCE BOARDS ALL
OF THESE THINGS HELP US GROW
INTEREST IN EDUCATIONAL.
OPPORTUNITIES IN TERMS OF
STUDENT SUPPORT I HAVE COME
FROM EDUCATION I KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES STUDENTS COME O OUR
SYSTEM AND THEY GET LOST. THEY
GET LOST IT'S VERY UNCLEAR HOW
TO GET TO THESE PATHWAYS. ONE
OF THE THINGS WE OFFER A FUTURE
HEALTH IS THAT WE HAVE A FUTURE
HEALTH NAVIGATOR THAT ONCE A
STUDENT IS REGISTERED WITH US
THE NAVIGATOR STAYS WITH THEM
THROUGH. DECIDING WHICH PROGRAM
TO GO TO DECIDING WHICH
EDUCATIONAL PARK PATHWAY MIGHT
BE THE BEST AND THEN ENCOURAGES
THING ENCOURAGING THEM THROUGH
THE PROCESS. THROUGH THE
FIFTEEN MONTHS TO HAVE SOMEONE
THAT IS ON YOUR SHOULDER YOUR
LITTLE ANGEL THIS IS SOMETHING
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF AND OUR
OUTCOMES HAVE SHOWN THAT- WE
HAVE A VERY HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
COMES UP SUCCESS OUTCOMES- FOR
OUR PROGRAMS. STUDENTS ARE
SUPPORTED ALONG EVERY STEP OF
THEIR JOURNEY- AND ON. PAIRING
FOR ANY LICENSURE EXAMS THAT
ARE NEEDED. ONE LAST THING I
WANT TO SURE ABOUT WHAT WE DO
THAT'S SPECIAL. WE HAVE WHAT'S
CALLED HUMAN TOUCH HEALTH CARE.
AGAIN YOU KNOW THAT MY
BACKGROUND IS RETAIL
HOSPITALITY AND TOURISM ONE OF
THINGS I PARTNERED WITH AT AT
MY AST ROLE WAS TO. INVITE UP
PEOPLE FROM HOSPITALITY TO LOOK
AT JOBS IN HEALTH CARE IT
ACTUALLY WAS PILOTED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WITH THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE AND SET UP. A
HOSPITALITY TO HEALTH CARE
POSITION YOU LOST YOUR JOB YOUR
RESTAURANTS CLOSED COME WORK
FOR- INSTITUTIONAL- HEALTH CARE
IT COULD BE LONG TERM CARE
COULD BE A SENIOR LIVING A
COULD BE A HOSPITAL. WE NEED
CULINARY PEOPLE THERE TOO. SO
ONCE YOU EVEN IF YOU HAVE THIS
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED THOUGH IT
MAY BE CHALLENGING. SO WE'VE
WE'VE CREATED HUMAN TOUCH
HEALTH CARE WHICH PROVIDES
COMPETENCIES IN. SIX AREAS
EMPATHY AND COMPASSION.
CULTURAL COMPETENCE BECAUSE
WE'RE TREATING PEOPLE FROM ALL
KINDS OF BACKGROUNDS. EFFECTIVE
COMMUNICATION EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE SO THEY CAN TAKE
CARE OF THEMSELVES TEAMWORK AND
COLLABORATION AND ETHICS AND
INTEGRITY ALL OF THESE
CONTEXTUALIZED AROUND A HEALTH
CARE SETTING. SO WE'RE SETTING
UP PEOPLE WHO ARE NEW MAYBE
HAVE NEVER HAD EXPERIENCE IN
THIS AREA SO THEY KNOW WHAT TO
EXPECT. WE ALSO HAVE THINGS
SUCH AS A MEDICAL TERMINOLOGY
INTRODUCTION COURSE SO YOU GET
THIS BEFORE YOU BEGIN YOUR
TRAINING. AND WE CAN HOPEFULLY
INCREASE THE SUCCESS FACTOR AND
WE ALSO HAVE- A SPANISH TO
ENGLISH CLASS WHERE YOU PEOPLE
CAN LEARN THOSE TERMINOLOGIES
ALSO AND HAVE THAT CONFIDENCE-
WE BELIEVE THAT APPRENTICESHIPS
ARE A WIN WIN. I WILL SAY THAT
NOT ONLY IS IT ERIC SPOKE ABOUT
THE BENEFITS TO EMPLOYERS AS
WELL AS WE KNOW FOR STUDENTS.
IT TAKES THE RISK OUT OF POST
SECONDARY TRAINING. I CAME FROM
IMMIGRANT FAMILY AS WELL I WAS
THE FIRST PERSON IN MY FAMILY
TO COMPLETE COLLEGE. AND IT'S A
HUGE RISK TO PUT ON YOUR
STUDENT- WORK OR PAVE PAY MORE.
AND WHEN WE DON'T WHEN WE HAVE
AN APPRENTICESHIP WE HAVE NOT
ONLY A JOB AT THE END BUT-
INDUSTRY RECOGNIZED CREDENTIAL
THAT MAKES YOU MORE EMPLOYABLE
GOING FORWARD. I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT IT'S REALLY. THE BRASS
RING WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
WHEN WE HAVE AN APPRENTICE IS
WE CONTRACT EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES. SO IN THE EDUCATION
WORLD WE TRAIN THEN WE COMPLETE
THIS CERTIFICATION WE HOPE THEY
TELL US THAT THEY GOT A JOB-
THIS- WE HOPE TO REPORT THEIR
WAGES BUT WE DON'T KNOW. WHEN
WE HAVE THESE APPRENTICES WE
CAN TRACK WHERE THEY ARE AND WE
CAN PARTNER WITH EMPLOYEES TO
ALSO UPSKILL EXISTING. UP WITH
EMPLOYERS TO X. UPSKILL
EXISTING EMPLOYEES AND BUILD ON
THAT SO- FOR US THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT INITIATIVE AND- I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FOCUS ON IT I FEEL THAT THE
TIME. WE ARE IN THE RIGHT PLACE
AT THE RIGHT TIME TO MAKE THIS
IMPACT TOGETHER IT AND I REALLY
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR- FOR
HAVING US HERE TO TALK ABOUT
THIS. WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED AND LAST WE HAVE
WITH US. PRESENTED AS VICE
CHANCELLOR O'BRIEN. THANK YOU
FOR PAYING TODAY. PARDEE
JOINING THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
LAST YEAR MISTER BRIAN WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS.
AT THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION.
OF A SHELTER WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TALKBACK TO
FOLLOW WILL DO MY BEST YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR RODRIGUEZ
AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS DAVID
O'BRIEN VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. FROM IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY
DISCUSSING THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
AND I WANTED SPECIFICALLY CALL
OUT AND THANK THE CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE THROUGH LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR AB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE.
OTHER WE THINK IT'S GOING TO
EXPAND THESE EARN AND LEARN
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
WORK FORCE BRIEFLY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS THE
SYSTEM OFFICE OVERSEEING
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. WE HAVE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES- AND
THE TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS WE SERVE INCLUDING
THROUGH A VARIETY OF WORK FORCE
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES LED BY
WORKFORCE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION. WE ALSO
PRODUCE SOME PRETTY OUTSTANDING
ALUMNI FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE OURSELF AS YOU CAN SEE.
I'M HAPPY TO DISCUSS SOME
CRITICAL COMPONENTS OF EARN AND
LEARN MODELS FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE RESPECTED
THE SYSTEM OFFICE PERSPECTIVE.
INCLUDING FLEXIBILITY AND
INCENTIVES AND HOW OR LEARN
HELPS PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION.
PROVIDE AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE
OFTEN PREDATORY FOR PROFIT
INDUSTRY. AS A RELEASE THE
FLEXIBILITY- A KEY COMPONENT OF
SUCCESSFUL EARN AND LEARN MODEL
IS FLEXIBILITY AS WE LOOK TO
EXPAND THEM YOU KNOW TO NEW
INDUSTRIES WE NEED TO BE
MINDFUL OF THE FACT THAT IT'S
NOT JUST GOING TO BE A LARGE%
BUSINESSES. RIGHT IT'S GOING TO
BE SMALL BUSINESSES AS WELL AS
WELL THAT YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE. WE
ALSO NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT
STANDARDS FOR APPRENTICESHIPS
AND- SITUATIONS WHERE THEY MAY
SET TOO HIGH OF A BAR FOR SOME
BUSINESSES TO PARTICIPATE WHICH
IN TURN MEANS THAT OUR COLLEGES
CAN'T PARTICIPAT BECAUSE A
BUSINESS PARTNERSHIP IS
REQUIRED FOR COLLEGES. SO WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE CONSIDERING
THE FLEXIBILITY TO PURSUE OTHER
MODELS OF EARN AND LEARN AS
WELL OUTSIDE OF THE FORMAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROCESS ALTHOUGH
DOES CONFIRM ANY BENEFITS AND I
WANT TO NOTE THAT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT GREATER FLEXIBILITY.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
COMPROMISING PROGRAM QUALITY
OR- LOWERING ANY OF OUR HIGH
STANDARDS FOR OUTCOMES.
COLLECTING QUALITY DATA AND
REPORTING ON OUTCOMES IS STILL
ESSENTIAL. AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE MORE COMMITTED TO
THAT THAN EVER. THANKS TO
INCENTIVES THERE DO NEED TO BE
SUFFICIENT INCENTIVES BUILT
INTO ENCOURAGE EMPLOYERS TO
WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
TYPES OF WORK BASED LEARNING ON
THE JOB- WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW BENEFIT
BOTH STUDENTS AND BUSINESSES
AND THEY NEED TO BE THE RIGHT
TYPES OF INCENTIVES SO WE THINK
ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE PAYROLL TAX
BREAKS AND CREDITS WHICH WE'VE
SEEN IN THE PAST AS A
SUCCESSFUL MODEL. ANOTHER
EFFECTIVE INCENTIVE WHICH
REQUIRES A LITTLE BIT MORE SET
UP FROM THE SORT OF GOVERNMENT
AND FUNNY PERSPECTIVE IS TO
SUBSIDIZE WAGES OF STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING IN WORK BASED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES WITH
EMPLOYERS SO UNDER THIS
APPROACH THE WAGES THE
NECESSARILY HAVE TO FLOW TO THE
EMPLOYER BUT COULD BE IN THE
FORM OF FOR EXAMPLE A STIPEND
THAT A STUDENT RECEIVES UNDER A
WORK BASED LEARNING PROGRAM
ANOTHER WAY OF SAYING THIS
WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE- PAYING
PEOPLE TO GO TO SCHOOL. RIGHT
AS AS JOY MENTIONED. THERE ARE
STUDENTS WHO SIMPLY CAN'T
AFFORD NOT TO WORK. BUT THEY
NEED THAT EDUCATION THEY NEED
THAT TRAINING SO WE CAN PROVIDE
THEM THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT. TO
COMPLETE THAT WATER GETTING
THAT TRAINING THEY'RE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO BE SUCCESSFUL. AS WE
LOOK TO NONTRADITIONAL
INDUSTRIES AND EXPANDING
APPRENTICESHIP AND EARN AND
LEARN THEIR I KEEP PRIORITY OF
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS
EXPANDINGBEYOND SOME OF THOSE
TRADITIONAL INDUSTRIES. AS WELL
AS MOVING BEYOND JUST HEALTH
CARE HEALTH CARE IS IMPORTANT
BUT IN THOSE MALLS ARE WELL
SUITED TO APPRENTICESHIP. FRONT
LOADED EDUCATION TRAINING WITH
HANDS ON PRACTICE AND SO FORTH.
BUT WE DO NEED THE FLEXIBILITY
AS MAJORITY LEADER REYES NOTED
TO EXPAND- NO LEARN INTO A NEW
AND INNOVATIVE INDUSTRY
SECTORS. SUCH AS BIOTECH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
TRANSPORTATION AND LOGISTICS
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING AND SO
FORTH SECTORS WITH GOOD LIVING
WAGE JOBS. THESE INDUSTRIES ARE
GROWING RAPIDLY ESPECIALLY IN
AREAS LIKE THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND HAVE SIGNIFICANT WORKFORCE
NEEDS THAT ARE NOT BEING MET.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN HELP
FILL THIS GAP. I WANT TO ALSO
NOTE THAT EARNING LEARN IN
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN SERVE AS
AN EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVE TO FOR
PROFIT HIGHER EDUCATION. FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES HAVE A SIZEABLE
PRESENCE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
BUT THEY OFTEN LEAVE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WITH HIGH AMOUNTS OF
DEBT. COMPROMISED THEIR ABILITY
TO REACH THE MIDDLE CLASS AND
DEGREES AND CREDENTIALS THE
DON'T DON'T AFFORD THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THOSE HIGH
WAGE JOBS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EARN AND LEARN PROGRAMMES.
PROVIDE A COUNTERBALANCE TO FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS WE OFFER
LOW COST HIGH QUALITY WORKFORCE
TRAINING TO CONSISTENTLY LEADS
TO HIGH PAYING JOBS. ANOTHER
POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS ON
CROSS AGENCY COLLABORATION. YOU
SEE MULTIPLE OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE AGENCIES REPRESENTED
HERE TODAY. IN ORDER FOR US TO
MAXIMIZE THE POTENTIAL OF
EARNING LEARN. EDUCATION THERE
NEEDS TO BE GREATER
COLLABORATION ACROSS THESE
VARIOUS PUBLIC AGENCIES. TO
REDUCE DUPLICATION. LEVERAGE
EACH OTHER'S RESOURCES AND
BETTER UTILIZE LIMITED FUNDS
FOR EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDING.
SUPPORTS TRAINING EDUCATION
BASIC NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND
FINANCIAL AID WHICH IS CRITICAL.
IT WOULD BE EVEN MORE EFFECTIVE
COUPLED WITH- JUST TO USE ONE
EXAMPLE LABOR AGENCY FUNDING
THAT COULD BE USED TO SUBSIDIZE
WAGES INTERNSHIPS ARE ON A
LEARN PROGRAMS SHARING OF DATA
ON OUTCOMES TO EXTEND MORE
SERVICES TO HELP THE STUDENTS
SEEKING WORK TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
IN THERE IS ONE FINAL CRITICAL
COMPONENT- THAT I THINK SPEAKS
TO WHAT THE MAJORITY LEADER
REYES EARLIER WHICH IS
INTENTIONALLY DESIGNING
WORKFORCE EDUCATION TO CLOSE
EQUITY GAPS. IT'S SO IMPORTANT
I. I DIDN'T HAVE IT PLANNED TO
ADDRESS MY REMARKS BUT- IT
OCCURRED TO ME AS THE MAJORITY
LEADER SPEAKING ON THIS THAT. I
VISITED ONE OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES RECENTLY. AT A- AND-
MY VOICE WANTS TO HELP OUT WITH
THIS PROBLEM. I VISITED ONE OF
OUR WORKFORCE PROGRAMS RECENTLY
I WAS A CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM WE
GOT TO MEET THE STUDENTS THEY
SHRED SOME INSPIRING
INCREDIBLE STORIES. ABOUT WHAT
I'VE DONE FOR THEM. BUT THERE
WERE NO WOMEN MMHM AND THIS
GROUP OF STUDENTS AND WE
POINTED IT OUT TO THEM. AND THE
INSTRUCTOR SAID HE AGREED THAT
WITH THE PROBLEM. AND IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT HE WANTED TO
WORK ON AND RECOGNIZED NEEDED
TO BE WORKED ON SO. I DON'T
HAVE THE ANSWER I WISH I HAD
THE ANSWER HERE TODAY BUT I
THINK THAT ARE TALKING ABOUT IT
I THINK OUR ELECTED OFFICIAL
CONTINUING TO PROCESS ON IT IS
PART OF THE ANSWER YEAH
DESIGNING. TO INTENTIONALLY
CLOSE EQUITY GAPS. SO I HOPE
THIS IS BEEN HELPFUL AND I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR AGAIN FOR
SHINING A LIGHT ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE- AND THE MEMBERS
FOR RAISING OTHER ISSUES AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WITHOUT
THE MOTION SIR- THANK YOU BOTH
AND I KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS WHICH I. ARE
QUICK ONE HERE FOR YOU JOY.
WHAT CAN BE DONE TO HELP
EMPLOYERS UNDERSTAND THE
BENEFITS OF THE EARN AND LEARN
MODELS ANYTHING MORE WE CAN DO
TO. INCENTIVIZE THEM AND GET
THEM UP TO SPEED WITH. I THINK
ONE OF THE BIGGEST THINGS THAT
WE HAVE GOING THAT'S A BARRIER.
WE'VE NEVER TOLD THE STORY. OF
WHY. WHAT'S IN IT FOR THEM AND
WHY IT'S NOT AS COMPLICATED AS
WE ALL THINK IT IS. YOU KNOW I
THINK I THINK. I'M LAUGHING
BECAUSE REMEMBER WHEN WE ALL
FIRST LEARNED TO DRIVE GO BACK
TO WHEN YOU WERE FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN YOU'RE LEARNING TO
DRIVE I HAD TO LEARN TO DRIVE A
STICK SHIFT AND IT SEEMS VERY
SCARY. AND THEN TO THINK ABOUT
RIGHT I LEARNED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO THIS IS MENTIONED
THAT IT WAS HOT. AND I REMEMBER
THE FIRST TIME GOING TO FREEWAY.
IT ALSO WHILE THAT FOR SOME OF
US BUT- THEN REMEMBER THE FIRST
TIME YOU DROVE IN A STORM AT
NIGHT. WHEN YOU'RE TIRED. OR
YOU HAD A CARLOAD OF PEOPLE AND
YOU WERE YOUR NAME WHY NOT
GOING THROUGH. NOW YOU DRIVE ON
THE EIGHTY YOU'REDRIVING WITH
YOUR KNEE OR TEXTING YOU'RE
DRINKING A LOT YOU KNOW I'M
JUST SAYING THAT. IT SEEMS VERY
HARD WHEN YOU ARE WE HAVEN'T
DONE IT BEFORE AND I WE JUST TO
HAVE A TOLD THE STORY. TO
EMPLOYERS IT'S ACTUALLY AT LESS
COST FOR THEM THEY GET FIRST
CRACK AT THE BEST AND MOTIVATED
EMPLOYEES. THEY GET TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE STANDARDS
THE WORK THE WORK PROCESSES
THEY COULD DETERMINE WHAT WILL
BE IN THE TRAINING. SO REALLY-
I THINK THAT AND THEN ALSO ON
THE PUBLIC SIDE ONE OF THE
THINGS I WORKED ON. IN THE MY
PASTORAL WAS. UP A HEALTHY
SCHOOL FOOD INITIATIVE TO TAKE
CULINARY STUDENTS TO GO TO WORK
AT A K. TWELVE. SYSTEM TO COOK
SCRATCH COOKED FOOD THAT IS
HEALTHY SUSTAINABLY GROWN
NEARBY. BUT THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM CAN APPLY TO
THE COPY FOR. GRANTS BECAUSE-
THEY HAVE A SET NUMBER OF.
FUNDS THEY CAN USE TOWARDS-
WORK AND THERE'S BARRIERS SO
IT'S A PUBLIC ENTITY THAT MAYBE
WANTS TO HAVE AN APPRENTICE OR
INTERN. BUT WE SOMEHOW NOT
CONNECTED THE DOTS SAME WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH WE ARE LOOKING AT
BUILDING UP PUBLIC WE WERE OUT
WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH I. T.
PROGRAM WITH CSU LONG BEACH AND
UC BERKELEY. BUT THOSE PEOPLE
END UP AT PUBLIC HEALTH-
OFFICES HOW CAN WE TAKE AWAY
THOSE BEARS S WE'RE NOT JUST
SUPPORTING PRIVATE INDUSTRY OR
ANY OF ANY SIZE BUT BE ABLE TO
HELP THEM ALSO PARTICIPATE IN
GETTING THESE WORKERS BECAUSE
WE NEED THEM OBVIOUSLY IN THIS
PUBLIC SECTOR. SO THAT'S THAT'S
A THAT'S A COUPLE AREAS I HOPE
WE CAN ADDRESS. ANY QUESTION
LIKE TWENTY MEMBERS. SMITTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YES WELL THANK
YOU BOTH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
TODAY AND I'M A GOOD ENJOY
FIRST BECAUSE ALWAYS REFER TO
WOMEN OF THAT THE INTERWAR THAT
THE SPEAKER WITH A PARTNERSHIP
THROUGH KAISER AND SEIU FOR THE
FOR TOUR HEALTH USER PROGRAM DO
THEY HAVE TO GIVE BACK AFTER
THEY'VE MADE THEIR INVESTMENT
IN THE STUDENT THEY HAVE TO
WORK SO LONG- THAT THROUGH
KAISER OR BE A MEMBER S. YEAH
YOU ASK IF THERE'S SO MANY.
GREAT QUESTION NO. OKAY SO
DURING THE COPA TIMES ARE ARE
WE ARE FULLY SCHOLARSHIP THING
ALL OUR STUDENTS THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO TAKE IN THE PROGRAMS.
AND- WHEN STUDENTS REGISTER
THEY ARE OFFERED THE OPTION TO
JOIN AS AN ASSOCIATE MEMBER OF-
S. C. R. U. H. W. YEAH BUT IT'S
AN OPTION THEY IT'S NOT A PRE
IT'S NOT A PRE REQUISITE OF
GETTING INTO THE TRAINING. AND
THEN ONCE THEY FINISH- THEY'RE
ALSO SHOWING THE BENEFITS OF
LIFE JOINING THE UNIT WOULD
HELP THEM AN EMPLOYMENT AND
MENTORSHIP AND SUPPORT. ALSO
NOT A REQUIREMENT FOR A COUPLE
ONCE YOU'VE COMPLETED SO
THERE'S NO. STRINGS ATTACHED
THERE IS A ONE HUNDRED DOLLAR
REGISTRATION FEE WHICH WE ASK
OF ALL STUDENTS SO WE KNOW THAT
THEY'RE REALLY INVESTED- OUR
TEAM IS ALSO WORKING ON PLACES
WHERE- TRACK FOR EXAMPLE IT OR
IN ORANGE COUNTY THE WORK FORCE
FOR THEIR HAS APPROVED THAT
THEY WILL. THEY WILL PAY FOR
THAT ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
THEIR CLIENTS IN THEIR-
EMPLOYMENT NEEDS SERVICES AREA-
BUT THEN THE TUITION WHICH CAN
RANGE ANYWHERE FROM EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THE R. FUNDING
COMPLETELY COVERS AND THERE'S-
THERE'S NO OBLIGATION THAT
THAT'S A GOOD THING I'M A PART
OF THE NONPROFIT WHERE WE PAY
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND WE
PAID A HUNDRED FIFTY STUDENTS
LAST YEAR. THAT HUNDRED DOLLARS
FEE SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
pMONEY YES HELLO. IT WOULD TAKE
A HUNDRED DOLLARS IS NOT FOR A
CHILD COMING OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
RIGHT THAT'S A GOOD CHUNK OF
CHANGE ABSOLUTELY AND THEN YOU
MENTIONED COPPER MOUNTAIN BARS
TO COLLEGE. BOTH OF THOSE ARE
MY DISTRICT VICTOR VALLEY
COLLEGE'S THERE WE'RE WORKING
WAIT GREAT WITH THE COMMUNITY.
COLLEGE SYSTEM TO TRAIN OUR
STUDENTS LITTLE KNOW THAT
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES AND THEIR
SCHOLARSHIPS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS YES STUDENTS BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO TIE THE SCHOLARSHIP.
WITH HOUSING SO THEY KNOW NO
WORRIES AT ALL THEN THAT'S
REALLY IS BIG IS A BIG
DISPARITY YOU STILL GOT A LIVE
AT HOME MOM AND DAD BECAUSE
THEY'LL PUT YOU UP. TO GO TO
SCHOOL BUT YOU GOT THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE STILL UP I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE
RELATIONSHIP FROM BUILDINGS.
THAT MAKE IT REALLY EASY FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. YEAH THE WORK
FORCE THE- TO. OF A OF- THE-
PERSON YOU WE SIX. CAN AND
REGIONAL- JULIE KEVIN IT AND
THEY'RE THERE AT EXCELLENT THIS
FOSTERING OF INNOVATION I'D
SAY. IT'S A TRUE A CHAFEE WAS
MENTIONED YOU KNOW SAMBAR DEER
VALLEY THERE'S- THERE'S- I
CAN'T EVEN TELL YOU. EXCITING
THINGS HAPPENING EVERY DAY.
EARLIER YOU HAVE A QUESTION
THANK YOU THE VICE CHANCELLOR I
DIE I AM A GRADUATE OF MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- MY HUSBAND
IS A TRUSTEE AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT HE WORKED
THERE FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS SO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE IN MY
BLOOD. AND I EVERY OPPORTUNITY
I HAVE I WILL ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
THE BENEFITS OF FOR STUDENTS TO
GO TO TWO YEARS AT LEAST TWO OR
THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHETHER
IT'S A- FOR CERTIFICATE OR
4 DEGREES TO TRANSFER WHATEVER
IT IS THEY WANT I AM ABSOLUTELY
SOLD ON COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS
THE BEST THING CALIFORNIA HAS
TO OFFER- AND NOT JUST OUR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS BUT- EVERYBODY
WHO WANTS TO GET THAT EXTRA
EDUCATION. SO I THANK YOU I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT- THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS-
SPECIFICALLY WITH OUR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THE THIS GROUP
MOST OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
RECEIVING FINANCIAL AID. HOW DO
WE- HOW DO WE ENTICE THEM SO
THAT THEY WILL EXPLORE THEIR
EARN AND LEARN PROGRAMMES
DURING THEIR TIME IN COLLEGE SO
WHILE TAKING THEIR REGULAR- I'M
SO SORRY TAKING THE REGULAR
COURSES BUT TO ALSO DO THIS
PROGRAM FOR- EARN AND LEARN.
YEAH THAT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION I WOULD SAY. YOU KNOW
THE GENERAL PRINCIPLE WHAT
WE'RE FINDING WITH- ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS IS.
THE REALITY IS THE LOT OF THEM
HAVE SO MUCH GOING ON YOU KNOW
THEIR LIVES ESPECIALLY SINCE
QUOTED. HOME SITUATION THIRD
DEALING WITH FAMILY YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE TAKING
CARE OF YOUNGER CHILDREN
PARENTS SIBLINGS WHOEVER.
WORKING MULTIPLE JOBS SO I
WOULD SAY AS A GENERAL
PRINCIPLE ONE OF THE THINGS
WERE OBSERVING. IS THAT- IT'S
BEST TO TAKE IT TO THE STUDENT
IF POSSIBLE. RIGHT SO THAT
COULD INCLUDE MODELS OF
OUTREACH WHERE- INSTRUCTORS AND
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS COME
INTO THEIR FELLOW INSTRUCTORS
CLASSROOMS WHICH I HOPE THEY
WOULDN'T BE WAS COMPETITION BUT
RATHER AS- RATHER IS A BENEFIT
RIGHT TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT
THESE PROGRAMS- THAT
ORIENTATION COMMUNICATIONS
COULD BE INCLUDED STUDENT
ORIENTATION- THAT COULD BE
INCLUDED WHEN STUDENTS GO INTO
THAT. FINANCIAL AID OFFICE TO
BE ON CHOIR ABOUT THE FINANCIAL
AID THE STATUS OF THE RAID. WE
CAN TRY TO ENSURE THEY GET
INFORMATION THROUGH THERE SO
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF WAYS BUT
ON THAT. STUDENT UP ON THAT
TOUR I WAS REFERENCING
RECENTLY. STUDENTS TOLD US TIME
AND TIME AGAIN. THAT IS MOST
EFFECTIVE IF THEY HEAR THAT
INFORMATION FROM A LOT RELIABLE
SOURCES AND AS MANY PLACES AS
MANY WAYS AS POSSIBLE SO I JUST
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A MATTER
OF. AFFECTED THEM REALLY
PERSISTENT OUTREACH TO A LARGE
EXTENT AND CULTURALLY COMPETENT
OUTREACH- YOUR OUTREACH TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES ARE LEAST
REPRESENTED IN SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND INDUSTRIES IS
GOING TO BE A MAJOR FACTOR IN
THAT AS WELL. THANK YOU AND IF
I MAY BE GOING TO CHAIR- I
NOTICED THAT FOR TO RUN HEALTH-
UNDER YOUR ACHIEVEMENTS THIS IS
WERE FOCUSING ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. WHAT A WHAT A GREAT
IDEA WE WOULD THAT'S ALL WE
HEAR ABOUT IS MENTAL HEALTH.
AND OF THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS- WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH COUNTERS OR DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH THERAPIST- BUT TO FOCUS
ON THAT. THAT'S IT IT'S
BRILLIANT AND I KNOW THAT.
THERE ARE MANY OTHERS- IN
COLTON WE NOW HAVE THE CAL CAL
MAD- WITH ALLIED HEALTH IT DID
PROVIDING- TRAINING ALSO. BUT
IT ISN'T THE KIND OF TRAINING
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE THE
LEARN AND EARN. MIKE MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS HOW CAN WE
SHOW THE BENEFITS OF
APPRENTICESHIP. TO THE PEOPLE
SEEKING THE TRAINING AND
EMPLOYMENT SO WE'VE ASKED A
QUESTION ABOUT THE EMPLOYERS
HOW DO HOW DO WE HOW DO WE-
SHOW THOSE BENEFITS. TO THOSE
WHO WOULD BE SEEKING THESE
APPRENTICESHIPS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION AND IT'S REALLY
BACK TO THAT STORY TELLING BUT
ALSO. WE JUST NEED TO CHANGE
OUR MINDSET ABOUT. HOW TO TALK
TO PEOPLE YOU KNOW AGAIN WHEN
WE WENT THROUGH COLLEGE. WE DID
IT ON A PRAYER AND THEN WE GOT
CHIU HANS BUT THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED AND THE WAY WE THOSE
SOURCES THE TRUSTED SOURCES
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IT'S NOT
JUST. LET'S PUT UP A YOUTUBE
CHANNEL AND LET'S LET'S MAKE
THIS HAPPEN THAT ACTUALLY IS
IMPORTANT- LETS IT RIP BELIEVE
OR NOT A TICK TOCK IS
IMPORTANT. BUT BUT I THINK. THE
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IT'S
REALLY SHOWING PEOPLE DOING IT.
IN THE COMMUNITY- ONE OF THE
THINGS WE ALSO BUILT UP ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SIDE WAS A-
IT'S NOW AT SEE YOU APPROVED
MICRO CREDENTIAL IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. SO IT'S A SHORTER
TRAINING THAT CAN BE DONE
ASYNCHRONOUSLY BUT IT COULD BE
VALUABLE TO ANYONE WHO IS A-
FACULTY MEMBER OR STAFF AT A K.
TWELVE. DISTRICT IT COULD BE
PROVIDED TO CITY EMPLOYEES OR
COUNTY EMPLOYEES AT OUR
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND SO- IT'S
REALLY KIND OF. DANCE YOUR
QUESTION- FROM THE STUDENT SIDE
WE HAVEN'T SAID WHAT THE
BENEFIT IS IT ISN'T JUST A
CREDENTIAL WHAT CAN YOU
ACTUALLY DO WITH IT MAYBE HOW
CAN YOU MAKE CHANGE. AND EVEN
OUR AVERAGE AGES THIRTY WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUNGER
FOLKS. THEY WANT TO SEE CHANGE
RIGHT AND SO WHEN WE CAN SHOW
THEM PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THAT
CHANGE WITH THESE. CREDENTIALS
WE'VE WORKED PARTNERED WITH
EDUCATIONAL PROVIDERS TO
PRESENT. I THINK IT BECOMES
REAL IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE SOME
FAKE JOB SOMEONE ELSE IS DOING-
WHEN SOMEONE SO THIS IS THIS
WOULD BE FUN TO MAYBE A PROJECT
WE CAN HELP YOU WITH FIND THESE
FOLKS TO PROFILE IN YOUR REGION
AND A PILOT HOW TO SHOW THEIR
PATHWAY MANY OF US HAVE COME
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
SYSTEM WE CAN ALSO HIGHLIGHT
THE COLLEGE'S. HIGHLIGHT THE
EMPLOYERS AND THEN MAYBE WE
PILOT ANAPPRENTICESHIP- IN
THAT AREA IT'S SOMETHING WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT AND-
FILLED. THANK THAT TELL THE
STORY LIKE ISN'T YES I MEAN
EVERYONE'S WATCHING THE LATEST.
NETFLIX OR APPLE SHOWS. THIS IS
IMAGINE- THAT'S MAYBE WE SHOULD
GET SOMEBODY IN ENTERTAINMENT.
THAT STORY OKAY GOOD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILL TELL YOU HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT. YES ON. I'M A
VIETNAM VETERAN THE LAST ONE TO
SERVE IN THE ASSEMBLY PROBABLY
LAST ONE FOREVER. WHEN I GOT
OUT OF THE MILITARY I WOULDN'T
BE SITTING UP HERE FOR WASN'T
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO MY
QUESTION IS. HOW DOES EARN AND
LEARN AND ALL THESE PROGRAMS
INTERFACE WITH VETERANS AND
ALSO THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE THEY
PROVIDE ALL THE MONEY SO HOW
YOU GET MONEY OUT OF THEM. THAT
THAT IS AN EXCELLENT QUESTION
ARE ARE VETERAN STUDENTS- YOU
KNOW IT'S A CLASSIC CASE OF.
THERE'S A I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
PROPER OF THE PROPER META FOR
PUBLIC POLICY TERM IS BUT I'M
SURE THE TEACHERS IN SOME
PUBLIC POLICY CLASS WORK THERE.
IS A FAIRLY WIDE IT'S YOU KNOW
SORT OF MENU OF BENEFITS IN
FUNDING AVAILABLE BUT SUCH A
COMPLEX WEB OF BUREAUCRACY AND
RED TAPE AVAILABLE YOU KNOW TO
ACCESS TO ACCESS THOSE
BENEFITS- WE HAVE STARTED
ROLLING OUT VETERANS RESOURCE
CENTERS A LOT OF OUR CAMPUSES
WHICH EFFECTIVELY SERVE AS A
ONE STOP SHOP. FOR VETERANS
STUDENTS RIGHT THE IDEA BEING
WE DON'T WANT TO KEEP SENDING
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY AGAIN WITH
WITH STUDENTS WERE MILITARY
VETERANS- AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR BENEFITS THAT ARE FEDERAL
STATE LOCAL PRIVATELY FUNDED
HAVE DIFFERENT APPLICATIONS
HAVE DIFFERENT ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA AND TO BE ABLE TO JUST
HAVE THEM GO ONE PLACE ON
CAMPUS INSTEAD OF FIVE OR SIX
PLACES. IS SO ESSENTIAL TO THAT
EXPERIENCE SO THAT'S SOMETHING
WE NEED TO CONTINUE WORKING
TOWARDS- I KNOW WITH THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF
OUR COLLEGES HAVE IN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS FUNDED IN RECENT
YEARS SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH BUT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. NOT FORCING STUDENTS
AGAIN ESPECIALLY STUDENTS FOR
VETERANS WHO'VE SERVED AND
COURT ELIGIBLE FOR A LOT OF
HEAT IN BENEFITS BUT WOULD HAVE
TO JUMP THROUGH SO MANY HOOPS
TO GET ALL OF THEM NOT FORCING
THEM TO JUMP THROUGH ALL THESE
HOOPS I GUESS THE BEST ANALOGY
WE BRING THE HOOPS TO THEM A
LOT OF JUMP THROUGH ALL OF THEM
AT ONCE OR SOMETHING BUT REALLY
HAVING A ONE STOP SHOP TYPE
MODEL. INCORPORATING EARN AND
LEARN A WORKFORCE EDUCATION
INTO THAT RIGHT THEY TO SHOULD
BE ABLE TO LEARN ABOUT
APPRENTICESHIPS WORKFORCE
pTHEY'RE APPLYING FOR THEIR GI
BILL OR THEIR OTHER FINANCIALLY
BENEFITS IT SHOULD ALL. BE IN
ONE PLACE AND ONE LOCATION FOR
THE THAT THIRTY MARCH THAT
GOING- SORRY MAY I ALSO. REALLY
QUICKLY JUST AT A TO THAT I'M
GLAD AND I KNOW MANY CAMPUSES
HAVE THAT WHICH IS WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE MY DAD SERVED IN THE
NAVY AND- I HAVE GREAT GREAT-
APPRECIATION FOR OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS. I WANT TO SAY THAT IN
MY PAST ROLE I HELPED BUILD
WITH THE VETERANS TRANSITION
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA- WE BUILT
UP FACILITIES MANAGEMENT AND
HOSPITALITY APPRENTICESHIP
PILOT. WITH THREE UP WITH ONE
MAJOR EMPLOYER JAIL L. AND
BECAUSE OF THAT SERVICES THE
VETERANS- TRANSITIONS ARE WAS
ABLE TO PROVIDE- TEN
APPRENTICES STARTED THAT
PROGRAM. AND IT WAS THROUGH
THAT- CERTIFICATION THROUGH THE
INTERNATIONAL FACILITIES
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION. AND
JAIL L. CAN. TAKE THESE
EMPLOYEES ANYWHERE GLOBALLY AND
THAT THE- WELL FUNDS WILL HELP
THEM WITH THAT MOVE WHICH MAKES
THEM PLAYER MUCH MORE EAGER TO-
SUPPORT THE APPRENTICESHIP. AND
THIS IS SOMETHING JAIL HAS DONE
IN OTHER STATES THIS WAS THE
FIRST ONE WE DID IN CALIFORNIA
JUST THIS PAST SUMMER. BUT
THEY'VE BEEN IN NORTH CAROLINA
FOR FIVE OR SIX YEARS SO THERE
ARE MODELS FOR HOW WE CAN DO
THAT WE CERTAINLY COULD DO THAT
WITH. SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS IN
YOUR IN YOUR REGION BECAUSE WE
CERTAINLY HAVE THE NEED. AND I
ALSO THINK BACK TO THE FAMILY
MEMBERS JUST LIKE WITH STUDENTS
AND THEIR PARENTS AND FAMILY
THE WHOLE COMMUNITY CAN
BENEFIT. WHEN THEY REALIZE THAT
THESE ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM SO
I JUST WANTED TO. SHARE THAT
THAT WEEK WE CAN USE THAT
MODEL- BUT IT'S ABSOLUTELY HAVE
A GREAT IDEA TO TAP INTO THAT.
GROUP ONE M. ONE LAST COMMENT-
SHORT COMMENT BECAUSE I HAVE
AIR TIME WITH YOU FOLKS
ESPECIALLY THE CHANCELLOR. I
WOULD LIKE TO HOME. REMIND YOU
YOU PROBABLY ARE ALREADY AWARE
THAT FEMALE VETERANS PER CAPITA
HAVE A MUCH HIGHER SUICIDE
RATE. THAN THE MALE VETERANS
AND TWENTY TWO VETERANS COMMIT
SUICIDE EVERY DAY IN AMERICA SO.
WHEN YOU'RE DESIGNING PROGRAMS
EARN AND LEARN INTERFACING WITH
THE VA EXCEPT A- THE FEMALE
VETERANS NEEDS SPECIAL
ATTENTION AND HELP- BECAUSE
THEY HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS THAT. I
COULD SPEAK FOR THREE HOURS ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
I HAVE THAT TO ASK QUESTIONS OF
FOR THE VICE CHANCELLOR. HOW DO
YOU KNOW BY CHANCE HOW MANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES USE PROGRAMS
AND CREDITORS THAT PROHIBIT
IRMA EARN AND LEARN. THAT WOULD
BE A GOOD NUMBER TO HAVE ON ME
BUT I DON'T AT THE MOMENT AS
ALL GET OUT WE'LL GET BACK TO
YOU TO STOP WITH THAT THAT'S
FINE. ALSO MOTIONS ARE WERE
BARRIERS ARE THERE TO
IMPLEMENTING EARN AND LEARN
PROGRAMMES AND WHAT CAN BE DONE
AT THE POLICY LEVEL TO
ENCOURAGE COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
OVER. COME THOSE BARRIERS. WELL
IT'S ALL TOO EASY TO SAY
FUNDING NORTH A FUNDING- YOU
KNOW FUNDING FOR THINGS LIKE
INCENTIVES. TO NOTE THAT- THAT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY ARE OUR
COLLEGES ARE DOING A LOT AT THE
MOMENT. WE APPRECIATE THAT WE
ADMIRE THEM SO MUCH SO I THINK
THAT ANY SUPPORT WE CAN GIVE
THEM THROUGH THE BUDGET. FOR
WHETHER IT'S- AS WELL AS
FUNDING FOR INCENTIVES FOR
PRIVATE BUSINESSES. TO GET
INVOLVED I'M BUT THERE MAY ALSO
BE YOU KNOW LEGISLATION THAT
CAN BE CAN BE PURSUED- I HAVE
FOUND IN YOU KNOW MY EXPERIENCE
OF HIGHER EDUCATION THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE. IN ADDITION TO THE
YOU KNOW THE SORT OF CLASSIC
VAL SHALL HAVE SHALL NOT TYPE
STATUTES THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
HAS A LOT OF POWER TO SET JUST
EXPECTATIONS. RIGHT AND IN THE
SYSTEM IS DECENTRALIZED
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES I
THINK- THE EXPECTATIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE GO A LONG WAY SO.
THAT WOULD BE A CONVERSATION I
THINK WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU OKAY STOP ON AS TO
WHETHER THERE'S SOMETHING. WE
CAN HELP PURSUE IS LEGISLATION-
TOGETHER IN THAT DIRECTION. YOU
CAN'T JUST ADD ON DRUG BURKE
CHAIR RODRIGUEZ- IN AGAIN I
STATED THAT THE INLAND EMPIRE
IS A HUB OF INNOVATION. AND I
KNOW IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM THAT. LAUNCH IS THE
APPRENTICESHIP HUB. IT'S BASED
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE IT'S THE
IT'S THE FIRST ONE. THAT REALLY
HELPED COLLEGES OPERATIONALIZE
APPRENTICESHIPS. SO ANOTHER
APPRENTICESHIP THAT WAS BROUGHT
OVER FROM ANOTHER REGION. THAT
I HELPED WITH WAS A VERY
CULTURAL OR IF IT A CULTURE
KNOWLEDGE IT WAS BROUGHT FROM
SAN DIEGO TO. THE AMOUNTS AND
YOU SENT TO COLLEGE BUT IT WAS
BECAUSE OF THE FACILITATION. OF
THE LAUNCH PROGRAM DIRECTOR IS
CHARLES HENCKELS BUT THAT'S
RIGHT IN YOUR REGION. THAT
COULD BE A MODEL BECAUSE I
THINK WHAT'S MISSING THIS IS
JUST MY OPINION BUT THE OPERAS
OPERATIONALIZE THE
OPERATIONALIZED I CAN SET YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
OPERATIONALISE LIGHT ISING. OF
AT THE COLLEGES OF HOW TO
CONNECT. TELL THE STORY
STUDENTS EMPLOYERS AS WELL AS
THE TRAINING FOR IT TO ACTUALLY
FUNCTION AND BE SUSTAINABLE.
THAT'S WHAT LAUNCH HAS BEEN
ABLE TO DO SO THAT WOULD BE A
PERHAPS ANOTHER IDEA TO- MAKE
SURE THAT IS HAPPENING IN EACH
REGION SO THAT THERE IS A HUB
FOR THE- FACILITATION OF
CONTENT SHARING AND ACTUAL
OUTCOMES. OKAY GREAT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO WITHOUT I
GUESS WE STILL HAVE SOME TIME
LEFT OVER COMING UP ON THE HOUR
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SOME
STAKEHOLDERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN PERSON AND ON THE
LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
WITHOUT FIRST WE HAVE BECKERT
ROSENBURG ROSENBAUM WITH THE
JUDGE FOR CHRISTMAS SERVICES
WELCOME BACK AYE YOU'RE HERE IN
PERSON. HAVING. OKAY OKAY YEAH.
MY GIRLFRIEND GET A JOB- I'M
REALLY HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
POWER AND LEARN MODELS- WE
TRAIN PEOPLE ACROSS OCCUPATIONS
AND SECTORS SECTORS THAT
DEMONSTRATED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ECONOMIC MOBILITY THESE ARE
JOBS THAT ARE IN DEMAND I DON'T
REQUIRE AN ADVANCED DEGREE AND
HAVE A GOOD ENTRY LEVEL WAGES
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ADVANCEMENT. THIS INCLUDES A
FOCUS ON HEALTHCARE TECHNOLOGY
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AND THE
SKILLED TRADES. INCLUDING A
PROJECT CALLED IP WORKS FOCUSED
ON CREATING APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMMING IN THE WATER AND
WASTEWATER INDUSTRY IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. OUR HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS WHICH SERVE
PREDOMINANTLY WOMEN OF COLOR
WITHOUT CLLEGE DEGREES HAVE
LONG USED EARN AND LEARN MODEL
SUCCESSFULLY. AN EXAMPLE OF
THAT IS OUR MEDICAL
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT
TRAINING PROGRAM WHICH ENROLLS
PEOPLE RECEIVING CAL WORKS IN A
SIX MONTH TRAINING. CLASSROOM
TRAINING FOLLOWED BY FOUR
MONTHS PAID WORK EXPERIENCE AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO. THESE GRADUATES GO
FROM A RELIANCE ON PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE INTO JOBS ON AVERAGE
EARNING TWENTY FIVE TO TWENTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR. THESE
GRADUATES TELL US HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO BE EARNING A WAGE NOT
ONLY TO SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND
THEIR CHILDREN. BUT ALSO TO PAY
OFF DEBTS THAT HELP THEM BREAK
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY. AND ALSO
TO FEEL LIKE REAL EMPLOYEES I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES
WE HEAR THIS OVER AN HOUR. OVER
IT TO BE TREATED LIKE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE SOMETHING OF VALUE TO
OFFER IS INCREDIBLY POWERFUL.
WE SERVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
EVERY YEAR. THAT ARE JUST
TRYING TO GET THEIR FOOT IN THE
DOOR INTO A GOOD JOB. HE'S VERY
VERY CRITICAL INDUSTRIES. WE
GET THOUSANDS OF APPLICATIONS
FOR OUR PROGRAMS. AND MANY OF
THESE APPLICANTS COME FROM
PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T HAD
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENTER INTO GOOD CAREER THROUGH
OTHER ROUTES. THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE MOTIVATED THEIR FACT
REFLECT CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
POPULATION. AND THEY DON'T HAVE
THE LUXURY OF TAKING TIME OFF
WITHOUT AN INCOME. WELL THE
BUILD SKILLS AND GROW IN THEIR
CAREERS. THESE PEOPLE HUGELY
BENEFIT FROM EARNING LEARN
MODELS THE INCOME THEY EARN
WHILE TRAINING FOR THEIR NEW
AREERS ALLOWS THEM TO CONTINUE
TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES THEIR
CHILDREN THEIR FAMILIES. KEEP
THEM FOCUSED ON THEIR GOALS
ALLOWS THEM TO LEARN
EFFECTIVELY AND GIVES THEM THE
DIGNITY OF BEING PAID FOR THEIR
HARD WORK AS THEY GAIN SKILLS.
AGAIN I SEE THIS EVERY SINGLE
DAY WE HEAR THIS OVER AND OVER
FROM OUR PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS
AND GRADUATES. PEOPLE CANNOT
INVEST IN THEMSELVES WITHOUT
THIS INCOME AND IT REALLY OPENS
UP ACCESSIBILITY TO A BROADER
POPULATION SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR ANIMAL
MODELS. THANK YOU BACK ON ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
THE JEWISH VOCATIONAL SERVICES
FOR. YOUR WORK IN THE DISTRICT
IN YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE. THIS YEAR WHICH
WAS SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR LAST
WEEK A. B. TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE. OPENS THE DOOR TO
ADDITIONAL EARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS AND
IT WAS A PLEASURE TO WORK WITH
YOU AND ENSURE YOU. TO GET THIS
BILL SIGNED AND ACROSS THE
DALLAS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WITH THAT TO HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE IN PERSON FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. SEEING NONE
WILL GO OVER TO OUR PHONE
LINES. AND WITH THAT I BELIEVE
WE HAVE SANDRA CISCO
REPRESENTING JEFFREY COMMITTEE
COLLEGE- CENTER ARE YOU THERE.
OPERATOR WE ARE TO HAVE
SOMEBODY ON THE LINE WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE SOMEBODY THERE.
THE OPERATOR HAS OPERATE ONLINE.
THAT'S YES I'M HERE WE DO HAVE
ONE ON THE LINE IS THAT AND-
THAT'S CENTER. ASSEMBLY
RODRIGUEZ CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN HEAR CENTER GO AHEAD.
GREAT THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND CHAIR
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ AND
DISTINGUISH SELECT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT MY
COMMENT TODAY. MY NAME IS
SANDERS DISCO AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE INDUSTRIAL
TECHNICAL TRAINING CENTER AT
CHEEKY COLLEGE. THE IN THE
INDUSTRIAL TECHNICAL LEARNING
CENTER ALSO KNOWN AS THE IMPACT
WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AS THE FIRST PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. WE HAVE A THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT TRAINING
FACILITY LOCATED ON THE SITE
CALIFORNIA STEEL INDUSTRIES. I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAJORITY LEADER ELOISE
GóMEZ RADIOS IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY FOR THE RECENT
BUDGET ALLOCATION AT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND AND
INCLUDE. A NEW STATE OF THE ART-
WELL THESE. GIVE YOU A BRIEF
WAVE THEM OF THE EMPIRE AT
TWENTY SEVEN SQUARE MILE THE
INLAND EMPIRE DESERT REGION IS
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
REGION BY AREA THE REGION HAD
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION
RESIDENTS IN TWENTY NINETEEN IF
THIS REGION WORK STATE IT WOULD
BE THE TWENTY SIX LARGEST BY
POPULATION IN THE NATION
BETWEEN LOUISIANA AND KENTUCKY.
BY TWENTY TWENTY FOR THE
REGION'S POPULATION IS EXPECTED
TO INCREASE BY FOUR POINT 4%
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED AND THREE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS EMPLOYMENT IS
EXPECTED TO INCREASE BY 8%
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND JOBS OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. THIS REGION IS
EXPECTED TO OUTPACE CALIFORNIA
OVERALL IN POPULATION GROWTH
AND JOB GROWTH OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS KEEP IN MIND THAT
DATA OUT ONE PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC WHICH I'M SURE HAS
ACCELERATED. THOSE NUMBERS.
APPLE SIR REVENUE IN MAINE
CAREER AND PROGRAMS ALIGN WITH
BUSINESS NEEDS IT'S CRITICAL
CONTINUE TO IDENTIFY AND
IMPLEMENT- LEARN OPPORTUNITIES
AND PROGRAM. ATKINS HAPPY CHEER
RETRAIN AND UPSKILL OVER A
THOUSAND INCUMBENT WORKERS
REGISTERED APPRENTICES AND MORE
THAN A HUNDRED UNEMPLOYED
UNDEREMPLOYED AND DISLOCATED
WORKERS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
WE PUT PEOPLE TO WORK IN IN
DEMAND INDUSTRIAL TECHNICAL
CAREERS AND REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIPS. WITHIN ENTRY
LEVEL WAGE RANGE OF TWENTY TWO
DOLLARS TO THIRTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR AN HOUR WITH AN AVERAGE
ANNUAL INCOME OF. FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO START.
SACRAMENTO AND BEEN TREMENDOUS
WE RECEIVED STATE AND NOW
RECORD FOR THE STRIKE WE'VE
MADE IN PARTNERING WITH
INDUSTRY. UPSKILL TRAINEES AND
PROVIDED QUALIFY TALENT POOL OF
INDUSTRIAL TECHNICIANS TO HELP
BUILD A HUNDREDS OF INDUSTRIAL
TECHNICAL JOBS THAT GO
UNFILLED. YEAR IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN INTACT PARTNERED WITH
MANUFACTURING AND LOGISTICS
EMPLOYERS. FORMALIZE THE FIRST
TWO COMPETENCY BASED REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP. PROGRAM IN THE
STATE OF. OVER THIRTY FIVE IN
THE REGION HAVE SIGNED ON TO
PARTICIPATE WITH MORE THAN
NINETY REGISTERED APPRENTICES.
A FRIEND TYPICALLY RECEIVE
THEIR JOURNEY LEVEL CERTIFICATE
AND APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT
FIVE YEARS GARNERING AN AVERAGE
ANNUAL INCOME. THOUSANDS NEED
TO PRESSURE PROGRAMS WERE
FUNDED WITH HUNDRED DOLLAR
GRANT FROM THE CALIFORNIA PREP
TRAINEESHIP INITIATIVE AND
FUNDING FROM THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM. IN ADDITION TO
THE PRESSURE PROGRAMS CHECK A
COLLEGE CONTINUES TO EXPAND OUR
WORK BASED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
STARTING TO MORE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS VOTE. ON THE CREDIT
SIDE. WITH ONE OF THE KEY MEET
WITH ONE FOR HUMANITY HEALTH
WORKER WE HAVE ALL WE ALSO HAVE
A PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM WHICH
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL INCENTIVES TO GET
EMPLOYERS TO GIVE TRAINEES WITH
NO PRIOR EXPERIENCE.AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENTER INTO.
MIDDLE SKILL JOB. ALL THE PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM COVERS WILL
CRY. WORKERS COMP IN LIGHT.
WITH THE EMPLOYER OF RECORD
BEING THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
SECOND THING IS TO PARTNER WITH
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE REGION
SUCH AS LAUNCH APPRENTICESHIP
NETWORK A REGIONAL COLLEGES
INTERMEDIARY DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS THE
DAMAGE YOU KNOW COUNTY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. A K. TWELVE
DISTRICTS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF YEARS AND WOMEN IN
REGISTERED PRE APPRENTICESHIP
AND APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF HIRING
CHIU APPRENTICESHIP SYSTEM
NAVIGATORS WILL INTENTIONALLY
RECRUIT AND MARKET THE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS ESPECIALLY
YOUNG WOMEN TO ENGAGE THEM TO
ENROLL IN LEARN AND EARN
MODELS. IN TECH HAS YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN ASSISTING THE
LOWEST SOCIO ECONOMIC CLASS IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE AND ELEVATING
AND EMPOWERING THEM INTO THE
MIDDLE CLASS POSITIONS WITH
LONG TERM CAREERS.
APPRENTICESHIPS HAS PROVEN TO
WORK TO PREPARE INDIVIDUALS
QUICKLY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
ALL OF THEIR NEEDS AS WELL AS
THE NEEDS OF THE INDUSTRY. EVEN
MORE SO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IS UNIQUELY DESIGNED TO
HELP STUDENTS BE SUCCESSFUL IN
COMPETENCY BASED APPRENTICESHIP
OR INFRASTRUCTURE ALLOWS US TO
RECEIVE. TO PROVIDE TUTORING
ASSISTANCE AID FOR BOOK
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND WE HAVE
STAFF THAT WORKS WITH EMPLOYERS
DIRECTLY TO ENSURE ON THE JOB
WORK DUTIES ALIGN WITH THE
INSTRUCTION THE APPRENTICES
RECEIVE. THE PANDEMIC HAS OF
CELEBRATED THE NEED FOR
INDUSTRIAL AUTOMATION AND
EXACERBATED THE LACK OF SKILLED
INDUSTRIAL MAINTENANCE AND
AUTOMATION TECHNICIANS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. MANUFACTURING
MANUFACTURE AND DISTRIBUTION
COMPANIES HAVE BEGUN LOOKING AT
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO HELP FILL
THEIR ORKFORCE PIPELINE.
EMPLOYERS ARE LINING UP TO
RECRUIT OUR STUDENTS AND WE ARE
STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP WITH THE
DEMAND. IN A KOBE RECOVERY AREA
WE NEED TO INNOVATE NOW MORE
THAN EVER THE INLAND EMPIRE HAS
A REPUTATION FOR INGENUITY AND
INNOVATION. TO DEVELOP WORK
BASED ON ANY COURSES PRO THAT
MADE BECAUSE FOR CRY. NON
CREDIT OR NOT FOR CREDIT. AND
BEGIN PRIOR- LEARN CREDIT FOR
LEARNING AND REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP PATHWAYS OR
STACKABLE INDUSTRY RECOGNIZED
CREDENTIALS. I MEAN FOR
LEARNING THEIR MODELS WILL
ALLOW COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
EITHER INTERMEDIARIES THE LIGHT
LIKE INTACT TO CONTINUE TO BE
DYNAMIC AND ADAPTIVE TO
EMPLOYER NEEDS AS WELL AS
SERVING THE UNEMPLOYED AND
UNDEREMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS TO
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC STABILITY AND
SUCCESS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I WILL. STAY ON THE LINE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SUNDAR WAS A PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH THE THIS YOUNG GETTING THE
FUNDING ALLOCATED EXPAND THE
CHAFEE AND TECH CENTER- WITH
THAT- OPERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE
ON THE LINE I DON'T THINK THERE
IS BUT CAN YOU JUST- CHECK ONCE
AGAIN. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN Q. AND WITHOUT THAT
PRETTY MUCH ROUNDS UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS AND
PARTICIPANTS FOR COMING TODAY.
THIS IS A VERY USEFUL
DISCUSSION IN THE COMING WEEKS
MYSELF WILL PREPARE A REPORT
WITH POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS AND
SHARE THOSE WITH YOUR OFFICES
AND ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED
THINKING.